General Court website.
The notice for this meeting complies with House Rules RSA 91A.
Anyone who has a problem accessing the meeting should call 271-3600 or email hcs at lake.state.nh.us.
In the event the public is unable to access the meeting, the meeting will be adjourned and rescheduled.
I want to introduce the staff that are on the meeting assisting us, Jennifer Floor, our committee researcher.
Please note that all votes that are taken during this meeting shall be done by roll call vote.
Let's start the meeting by taking a roll call attendance.
when each member states their present, please also state whether there is anyone in the room with you during this meeting.
start the meeting by taking a roll call attendance.
When each member states their president, please also state whether there is anyone in the room with you during this meeting which is required under the right to know law.
Representative Bernstein, you want to take the roll.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman.
Let's begin the roll call with Representative Patrick Abrami.
Representative Charles Melvin who is sitting in for Mary Griffin.
Here.
Representative Jordan Oury.
Representative Ober.
Here with two cats.
Representative Doucette.
President Obramie.
I am Alan Berstein, your clerk, and I'm in my home office by myself.
Representative Robert Elliott.
I'm here, and my wife's in the bedroom.
Representative John Janijian.
I'm here in Salem, New Hampshire.
My wife and daughter are somewhere in the house.
Representative Herschel Nunez.
Representative Nunez.
Representative Tim Baxter.
Thank you, Representative.
I'm here alone in my house.
Representative Spilsbury.
Here in my home in Charlestown alone.
Representative Tudor.
Here in Northwood alone.
Representative Almi.
Here in Lebanon in my house alone.
Representative Ames.
I'm here in Jeffrey in my home office alone.
Representative Southworth.
Here in Dover alone.
Representative McCoy.
Here in Greenland, New Hampshire in my home alone.
Representative Schomburg.
Here at the LOB.
Representative Edith Tucker.
Here in Randolph alone.
Representative Gomarlo.
Here in Swansea alone.
Representative Tom Loffman.
Representative Loffman.
Representative Amanda Gorg.
Here in Lee by myself.
Representative Mary Hacken Phillips.
Good morning.
I'm present this morning from my office in Concord, New Hampshire alone.
Representative James Murphy.
Good morning.
I'm here alone in my office in Hanover, New Hampshire.
Representative Norman Major.
Here in the LLB room.
There are 22 of us present.
Two of us are absent.
Thank you, Representative Bernstein.
We're going to start the first public hearing, which was scheduled for 9 o'clock.
And since I'm going to be testifying, Vice Chairman, Representative Bromney is going to take over.
I open the public hearing on House Bill 306.
Relative to revenue estimates while operating under emergency orders caused by the COVID-19 pandemic.
Just so everyone knows, the only one signed up to justify is Representative Major.
So Representative Major, please introduce yourself.
Thank you, Representative Obramny.
House Bill 306, relative to revenue estimates while operating under these conditions, What this bill does, it just backs up what we're doing by statute.
And what we're doing is we're trying to react to the revenues as the revenues are varying due to the pandemic and other causes.
That means we may end up doing revenue estimates every month for this fiscal year until the pandemic is over.
So this backs up work done by statute.
That, wait a minute.
Representative Almey.
Thank you.
The way this is worded, it applies only to the pandemic.
And it means that in future emergencies, if we felt the need for this, that we'd have to put in another bill.
on do you think we ought to amend it to any emergency orders in the future or something like that?
I think it stems partly from the difficulty we had getting some of the agencies to respond last fall when we were trying to get an update and last summer when we were trying to get an update on things.
I can respond to that.
I would rather keep this a clean bill and just have it exist during this pandemic.
If I could just do a brief follow-up for the committee.
I went into the history of revenue estimates when I first became chair.
And none of what we do is actually in statute.
It's just tradition that evolved since 1971, I think it was, when the Senate decided that there had to be a revenue estimate process.
The next year, they handed it over to the House.
Okay.
Did you say Representative Ames?
I didn't hear that.
Okay.
You're really echoing, Pat.
I know you're doing your best.
Sorry, my little idea.
Wow.
So I'm really following up on Representative Alamey's question.
My sense is that this is not necessary, that the statutes clearly give us authority to proceed with estimates on our own schedule when we think it's important.
And so my question to Representative Major really is why do we need this?
It was recommended that I put this in in order to be able to back up what we've been doing, which is different than normal by stature and only make it available during the pandemic.
Any follow-up?
No, no follow-up.
Any other questions?
If there's any other members of the public on this Zoom call, would you like to speak?
Please raise your hand.
Can someone talk to that please, Jen?
Excuse me?
Do you see any other hands up?
Any people in front of the public out there?
I do not.
So if there's no other questions, I'm going to close the hearing on Haskell.
It's been recommended that after you speak, you mute yourself, as well as representative major, and then those two devices won't be conflicting all right very good we're going to move on to our next bill i'm hoping to hearing on house bill 324.
The administration is being passed by the Department of Revenue Administration.
And the current is once again the representative major.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This bill has been put in at the request of the Department of Revenue in order to be able to clear up, clean up some of the processes that they have.
And Carolyn Ward from, I believe it.
Carolyn Lear will be here.
Carolyn Lear will be here to explain.
Okay, any questions?
President Major.
.
Good morning, representatives.
Carolyn Lear, assistant commissioner at the Department of Revenue here.
Could someone give me at least a thumbs up that you can all hear me fine?
Yes.
All right.
I'm going to be pretty brief with you today because I hope that you all received the letter that we sent around explaining this legislation that we've requested.
I would characterize the bill as some technical cleanups as well as some hopefully statutory improvements that will sort of go well with our new revenue information management or RIMS system.
I think section one of the bill is by far the most significant change that we're asking for today.
Currently under statute, all of our taxes are assessed interest on a daily basis.
And what that means is that a taxpayer could receive a bill on one day and then it is immediately wrong because the interest is accruing on a daily basis.
This bill would allow us to assess interest more like a credit card bill, which is to say that we would send a taxpayer a bill and the dollar value on that bill would be good for up to 30 days.
And then if they hit that 30 day, the prior 30 days of interest will appear on their next bill.
So we think this is a pretty taxpayer-friendly change, and it will also ease our administration because we find ourselves either billing or writing off these small balances of interest when taxpayers don't calculate their daily interest rate correctly.
Sections two and three relates to the administration of the meals and rentals tax.
It eliminates telefiling from the statute because we have eliminated the ability to telefile.
Very few taxpayers used that.
Taxpayers have very successfully transitioned to using GTC and it's saving the department about $100,000 a year.
The fourth section relates to the department's tax expenditure report, and it eliminates a somewhat outdated calculation that we perform in that report related to the transition the transition from three-factor apportionment to three-factor apportionment with double-weighted sales.
As you all know, the state is now considering going to single sales factor.
We don't think that it's valuable to continue to compare the impact of going back to the way we did it in 1994.
And then lastly, can I stop you there?
We actually have the same language cross out in in a bill that I filed on the single sales factor bill.
Yes.
So I guess it does.
I guess these two will be reconciled if we we pass it with this language in here?
Yes, and I believe the language is exactly the same.
Okay, thank you.
And then the last section of this bill relates to the due dates in the business tax statute for nonprofits.
As some of you recall, three or four years ago, the federal government changed their due dates for business taxes, and we mirrored those changes statutorily as well.
Unfortunately, we were a bit unartful when we did that because we failed to accurately account for nonprofit filers, of which there are not many, but we just thought it was important that the statute accurately reflect the due date for nonprofits, which is actually May 15th for most filers.
With that, I will stop talking and I'm happy to answer any of your questions.
Representative Alming.
Are you still muted?
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I apologize.
I cannot find that letter.
Could you tell us when you sent it or who sent it?
I sent it to the chair and your support staff on either Friday or Monday.
I forget, but I can absolutely send it around again, if that would be helpful.
That would be terrific.
Thank you.
It was with the fiscal note that came.
It was attachments.
Yeah, it was from Gen 4.
It was there were three or four attachments.
That's correct.
That's my understanding, too.
Bevacemi Almi, do you have a follow-up?
You're still muted.
You're muted.
I muted you.
I thought you were done.
I'm sorry.
You need to unmute.
I apologize.
Apparently the space bar doesn't work while I was searching.
I found it.
I have no follow-up and I shouldn't ask actual questions because I'm a co-sponsor.
That's right.
I just noticed that myself.
Representative Major wants to add something here.
Okay.
For those that don't have the letter, what I would recommend is that we will resend that letter out.
And then we can discuss this on the 10th when we do a work study meeting, reviewing the bills that we have heard thus far.
That's it.
Representative, how are you?
Your hands are open.
I guess you're not in a lot.
Good.
We can't hear you again, but I just wanted to make another comment.
I have found it, and the reason that I couldn't find it is probably relevant to other people.
It is labeled DRAFNQG for two four hearings, which is a little cryptic.
If it said quick guides, I would have gotten it open quicker.
I'm sorry.
Okay, well we could talk to Jennifer about how we label things in the email.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Okay, any other questions?
Is there any member of the public?
Jen, is there anybody else out there?
Alan, We'll see you next time.
Any questions?
Okay, I see none.
Is there any member of the public?
Jen, is there anybody else out there?
Allen?
There's one member of the public that has his hand raised.
Okay.
I will allow him to talk.
Yep.
Kevin Kennedy, you're unmuted.
Thank you.
My name is Kevin Kennedy.
I'm a CPA here in New Hampshire.
I also am a trustee for the New Hampshire Society of CPAs, and I also sit on the Tax and Legislation Committee as co-chair, and I just wanted to comment that the conversations among the society are we do support this bill and the DRA's administrative changes.
That was it.
Thank you very much.
Any questions?
Mr.
Kennedy?
Seeing none.
Okay, I think we...
I forgot to do this in the left first bill.
But here is one person signed up in support, and that was Eric Rathbotton.
With that, seeing no other hands, I'm going to close the hearing on House Bill 324.
I'm going to hand the chair back over to Representative Major for the next bill.
No, you're going to chair it, is it?
We have House Bill, we have.
We have another 528.
134.
We have 528.
There's one in between.
528.
Okay, yes.
Sorry about that.
Okay.
I hope so we are good.
We're running late.
Okay.
I opened the public hearing on House Bill 528-FN relative to electronic filing of state tax returns.
And one second.
I got to find the seat.
Representative Gonski is in.
The sponsor.
Okay, Representative Gonski.
I am here.
Introduce the bill.
Can everybody hear me?
Yes.
Thank you.
I am here.
Introduce the bill.
Can everybody hear me?
Yes.
Excellent.
Having some of these difficulties in our committee, I completely understand what you're going through this morning.
Okay.
Good morning, Mr.
Chair and members of the Ways and Means Committee.
For the record, I am Representative Michael Gunsky, and I represent Hillsborough 6, the town of Gostown.
I was asked to file this legislation by my personal CPA, Jeff Chickering.
Mr.
Chickering has a small firm located in Manchester, and he prepares tax returns for a number of New Hampshire businesses.
Most of the information I will be providing has been provided by Mr.
Chickering, so I would ask that his testimony follow mine, and that if members of the committee have specific questions, it may be best for him to answer those for you.
At the present time, New Hampshire does not require electronic filing or e-filing of income and business tax returns.
This includes individual returns, interest in dividends, tax returns, business tax returns such as business profits and business enterprise and also non-profit annual returns.
The bill you have in front of you puts in place an e-filing requirement for practitioners that will ensure that all vendors make their tax software capable for New Hampshire e-filing.
Just a little background, all New England states and New York, except the state of Vermont, and most states throughout the United States have mandated e-filing requirements.
Certain professional tax software vendors will not make New Hampshire e-filing available unless it is required.
Some claiming the complexity of our New Hampshire tax code is a reason for not offering an e-filing product.
This is a problem for a large number of practitioners in the state of New Hampshire, many of them small, as well as what I see as the New Hampshire Department of Revenue.
Practitioners whose software vendors will not allow for e-filing must print returns, send them to their clients for signature, and then mail the returns to the DRA along with the appropriate copies of the federal tax return that are required by New Hampshire laws.
When the New Hampshire DRA receives the paper returns, they must scan them into their system, hard key all the data into the state's electronic system, and it seems to be hardly an effective or efficient system.
It seems to me it would be time consuming for the New Hampshire DRA employees and time could be allocated to areas such as providing better customer service as well as focusing on audits of tax returns.
This is the year 2021 and with the current pandemic situation it seems most everything around us is taking advantage of the technology we have.
Submitting tax returns electronically that are being prepared in quantity by a tax preparer seems to me to be a logical solution, especially during a time with this COVID pandemic.
Regarding the fiscal note, I see a positive impact to the Department of Revenue.
There should already be systems in place for approving software vendor requests, and I have to believe there would be efficiencies gained within the agencies with taking the bulk of the manual entry from the returns away from the employees.
And thank you for my testimony.
That sums it up.
Thank you, Representative.
Questions from the committee?
Any questions from the committee?
I've promoted Jefferson Chickering to panelists.
Thank you, committee.
Okay.
Next, Jefferson Chickering.
Hi, I'm here.
Can everyone hear me?
Yes.
Thank you.
As Mike mentioned, I've been as accountant for several years.
I'm a CPA in Manchester.
I've had my own firm since 2003.
I formerly served on the State Board of Accountancy.
I was appointed by Governor Benson in 2003, reappointed by Governor Lynch in 2008.
So I've been involved with a lot of accountancy legislation over a 10-year period.
I also served on the National State Board of Accountancy, which kind of worked with all the states regarding accountancy legislation around the whole country.
I did that from 2010 to 2013.
And over the years, I've talked with Mike several times as I've done his work saying, you know, it's just so frustrating that vendors just will not comply with e-filing.
Some vendors do, some vendors will not.
So that's sort of the genesis of this bill in a sense that there's a whole history of e-filing when states came online, when they started doing it.
And then it sort of became, well, when states start requiring it, vendors certainly become compliant because they have no choice.
So that's sort of where we're at at this point in time.
And every vendor has a different perspective on e-filing.
Every year as I go to renegotiate my fees with my vendor, I say, is New Hampshire going to be e-fileable next year?
And the response every year is that it will only be, you only be able to e-file in New Hampshire if the state has a requirement that e-filing has to happen in New Hampshire.
So in essence, it's sort of what my discussions with my representative Gunsky have Thank you.
filing has to happen in New Hampshire.
So in essence, it's sort of what my discussions with my representative Genski have revolved around.
A little more history, as far as my practice, I e-file in around 15 to 20 different states every year.
And I e-file in all of those states except my home state of New Hampshire.
And again, it's because my vendor will only make it available if New Hampshire requires e-filing.
My vendor offers about 45 states for e-filing.
The states that are not offered, of course, is New Hampshire.
And I'm just trying to give some examples to help with context.
New Hampshire, Washington, Nevada, South Dakota, and Wyoming are the states that are not required or my vendor does not make available.
And the interesting note on that is that Washington, Nevada, South Dakota, and Wyoming, they do not have business income taxes.
So they have a lot less tax filings.
But then it leaves New Hampshire, we have business income taxes, we have individual taxes, as far as interest and dividends.
We have many, many different types of taxes, and it's very complex here.
So basically, you get to the point where a lot of vendors just don't want to deal with making New Hampshire available for electronic filing, unless, again, it's required.
So we kind of get into the complexity of New Hampshire law.
A lot of states that are available, there's sort of a piggybacking system you could call that when you file your federal return, your state return, just sort of go along with it.
They go through the IRS and then they go to the state.
So it's sort of a piggybacking.
And a lot of state laws have a relevant conformity to federal laws, where when we get to New Hampshire, we have the complex business enterprise tax, business profits tax, the personal compensation deduction, different rules for corporation dividends, partner distributions.
So it is very complex.
And that is sort of one of the reasons why some states may stay away from making e-file for New Hampshire available.
Again, unless it's a requirement, they may stay away from it.
I'd say right now, as far as I have counted, there's about 32 states in the country that have this requirement.
And again, of those, of the 50 states, plus you can include DC as an entity of 51, 45 or 46 are available for e-filing through my specific vendor.
It's just those five states.
And of those five states, New Hampshire is the only one with business taxes.
So, so sort of, I know Mike touched on the Northeast states and we include Pennsylvania and New Jersey, New York, all of the six New England states.
Only two of them don't have required e-filing.
That's New Hampshire and Vermont.
However, Vermont makes e-filing is available.
My vendor makes it available because it's less complex tax law.
So I e-file in Vermont all the time with clients.
We just can't do New Hampshire.
I guess some of my other notes are, you know, how this is sort of a win-win for the state, for the Department of Revenue, for practitioners, for all stakeholders in a sense.
Sort of reviewing the fiscal note from the DRA.
I know like there's a lot of, what happens is they get all these paper returns and they, people have to sit and scan them in all the time, which they have to sort of get pulled off from what they're doing when they get a mad rush of returns.
They have to scan them in paper and then they have to review them.
And it's with a different methodology.
It just seems as just an opportunity cost lost by not requiring e-filing.
There's just resources that could be dedicated that way.
There isn't a whole department that approves e-filing, works specifically with vendors on e-filing.
There's a whole process already in place um there's one thing too even on the state returns in the upper left hand corner a lot of people can note that it always says do not staple so the department of revenue has on their forms to not staple their tax returns and i always found that curious and the reason they say that is because if you staple the returns before you send them to the Department of Revenue, they have problems scanning them in because they pull the staples out, it might tear some of the corners of the return.
So if you're a practitioner like me, you have to print off New Hampshire returns, you have to print off a copy of the federal return.
You can't, you don't staple it because the state says don't staple your return.
So you put it on a black binder clip.
You set it up to be mailed to your client.
Client receives it in the mail with a black binder clip.
They take the black binder clip off.
they sign it, they lose pieces, it gets to the DRA and oftentimes they'll get a notice saying we're missing this piece of paper, missing this piece of paper.
It's almost as if this, because this whole process just is inefficient for every stakeholder, it just can go sideways at times.
So I mean, just simply put electronic filing requirement avoids all of these hassles.
Thank you.
So I mean, just simply put, electronic filing requirement avoids all of these hassles.
That's sort of most of what I wanted to share.
I do think it also levels the playing field from bigger firms and smaller firms.
Smaller firms don't always have the resources for the most complex tax software and the more complex and sophisticated tax softwares, they'll make New Hampshire e-filing available.
Some of them do, some of them don't.
So the smaller firms were at a disadvantage because we don't have a requirement.
and our vendors may tend to ignore a state like New Hampshire that has more complex tax laws.
So, I mean, even where I sit in my office here in the North London Manchester, I can count seven firms using the same software, excuse me, seven practitioners using the same software within a two mile radius of where I am.
So I don't have a number of how many firms in this specific software are using in New Hampshire, but I could estimate 50 to 75 perhaps, but that's just one software vendor.
There's many other vendors that will still not make New Hampshire available.
So that's most of what I wanted to share.
I just think New Hampshire's been way, way behind the times on this.
It's just time to do it.
So that's pretty much what I wanted to share with you guys.
And thank you for letting me give some testimony.
I'm happy to answer and field any questions.
Thank you for your testimony, Mr.
Chickering.
First question is Representative Brownlee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for your testimony.
I've been in and out with technical difficulties.
The line for the bill says a tax return should be required to take on a quick while tax return.
So why the bill went the other way around that providers of this technology should be required to offer a few messages to the future?
Thank you.
around that the provider of this technology should be required to offer a message to the reason I say that there may be some small guys out there that still don't want to file electronically could be retired accountants that are doing maybe five parents or neighbors or whatever that are just going to do paper have you and also can you explain line six in the the bill where it says the 25 is that where it's handled that you have to prepare at least 25 that to how do we protect the guys that still want to do it manually?
Sure.
Yeah, I'm happy.
I had a little trouble hearing you but I think I got gist of what you're saying, Representative Abrami.
So let me try to address that particular part of the bill.
So I don't think there's a goal of this bill to preclude anyone from being in business as a preparer.
I think the intent of this bill is essentially for anyone using tax software to have a requirement to e-file if you file a certain amount of returns.
Now, I understand what you're saying.
Yes, there's a lot of folks that may be retired and doing stuff part time, or sort of a hobby for them, they're a tax return preparer.
And the response I have too is that it's very hard to prepare any taxes without any tax, without tax software, like actually physically preparing it by hand.
It's very uncommon at this point with technology.
However, the only amendment that I might propose to this is that there be an opt-out that you could get permission from the DRA if someone, Abrami in the in the situation that you're mentioning simply doesn't have the technology available to them then there should be an opt-out provision where they fill out a form and send it to the DRA and say hey I'm doing a certain number of returns this year or whatever the situation you know just I want to check a box that I'm going to be sending them in by hand.
And I think, I think the process really could be that simple to address that concern.
All right.
Thank you.
A follow-up?
So yeah, I think you understand my concern.
I don't think we want to restrict anybody from performing a service that they have a skill to do.
And that's my concern.
So when we hear from, we're going to be hearing from Ms.
Lear from DRA in a few minutes.
Maybe she can help us out with this.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Norm, I had to mute you while Patrick was talking, so you need to unmute.
Thank you.
Okay.
Representative Elney has a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'm going to have some questions for DRA also, but on two things.
One, isn't this going to increase considerably the price of the software for vendors?
Because it is going to take quite a lot, as you were saying, for the software companies to set up a proper electronic form for New Hampshire, given the complexity of our software.
And second, do you know of any vendors that we could contact to talk to us about this?
Thank you for your questions, Representative Almey.
My response and take is that it really doesn't increase the cost of the software being passed on to the consumers.
Being practitioners, that it's part of what they do, and they have their own fully dedicated departments that are working with all states all the time.
And as Carolyn can testify, the DRA is a whole department that's already dedicated to it.
So in a sense, it's essentially just opening up some tunnels and making sure some approvals get back and forth for it to happen.
So I really do not believe there's any increased cost to consumers.
As an example, my software is a fixed fee software.
So I pay just X amount of dollars per year for the privilege of the federal program in all the states being all e-file everywhere.
So I do not believe saying New Hampshire e-filing would increase the cost of any software.
I truly don't think that will.
I don't.
Hopefully that helps answer that question.
And as far as vendor contacts, the DRA already has relationships and contacts with many, many vendors in place already that are currently using, currently making their whatever software they have available for New Hampshire D filing.
So I'm sure there's absolutely a way to, well, if the vendors could find the time and be party to a call, I'm sure there would be a way to have them participate.
I'm just not entirely sure if I could do it, because I don't have those established relationships with all the other vendors, but I know the DRA certainly does.
Thank you.
That's a very good suggestion for how to contact them.
I wasn't worrying so much about the consumer as about the CPA, particularly the ones that are on their own.
yeah and that that really is what i was trying that sort of was what i was trying to relay that the cpa is that there isn't really going to be from the seat i sit in there'll be no increased cost when if my vendor said new hampshire now has a requirement it's just a matter of they already have a fully dedicated department it's a few people on their end working on that tunnel with new hampshire so as a service provider it would not increase the cost for me and i'm really not sure if it would increase the cost all all across the board it's usually a fixed fee you either check a box for state e-filing yes or no and you pay for sort of the whole all the states you don don't pay like by the state.
Some may pay per return.
I'm not sure.
But some may pay per return e-filing.
Usually that's a really minor fee, like a $10 extra fee per e-file to get it through the tunnel electronically to the state.
And it goes to the IRS first, and then it comes back down to the to the state so but there if there's a fee it'd be so in my opinion very very minor but mostly I don't believe there would be a fee.
Representative Janjigian.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman.
Chickering for your testimony.
My question, I'm just an individual who prepares my own taxes using TurboTax.
And I noticed I do end up owing a business profits tax and a dividends tax.
And when I finish, TurboTax is preparing those state returns, the New Hampshire state returns.
But you're right, at the end, I get to a point where it says, print them out and mail them in.
So is the, I just want to understand is the problem that DRA does not accept, you were talking about the vendors, but the vendors already preparing the tax.
Does DRA not accept?
Oh no, sorry, I mean to interrupt you.
The DRA accepts e-files currently for New Hampshire for all returns it's really a per vendor basis whether or not they're they make it available and they've worked with the state with the DRA's e-filing approval system to have it in place so my guess is I don't use TurboTax I'm not too familiar with the nuances of it, Representative Janigian.
But that's not uncommon that you get to that point.
And then you can't really move any further where you sort of just stuck with, okay, I have to print and mail it to get it to where it needs to go at that point.
I'm not sure if I'm answering your question.
Does that address it?
I think you are.
So you're basically saying that DRA is ready to accept that electronic filing.
It's just that TurboTax, in this case, hasn't worked with DRA to work on the actual transmission part of it.
Correct.
Absolutely.
So the DRA has e-filing acceptance capabilities, and they accept many from many vendors.
It's just if you have this word or this type of legislation passed, then the vendors have no choice, but to make that the wall that you hit, basically they have to comply with state law and say, okay, well now we've got to make it available for New Hampshire.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Any other hands?
So, Alan.
Representative Bernstein.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you, Mr.
Chickering, for coming and testifying in front of our committee.
It sounds to me like the vendor you deal with isn't offering this service.
Why wouldn't you just switch vendors?
And if there's enough CPA firms like yours, where there's a void in the marketplace, they just go to another vendor.
I don't understand why the market isn't just taking care of this.
Well, thank you for your question.
It really is a matter of cost.
And if smaller firms such as myself were to switch to a larger vendor, we're talking of incurring costs of anywhere from $5,000 to $8,000 a year just to switch to a higher level vendor.
so i i I, I totally understand your question.
I, I definitely appreciate it.
There's a huge cost to switching vendors.
There's also an immensely high learning curve of switching vendors is awesome.
Many problems for vendors say, Oh, all your, we'll do a big data conversion to bring all your clients from that software to another software.
It's always so messy and such a headache.
I did it once many years ago from one vendor, which was actually part of the Intuit family that representative Janigian is using on TurboTax, a higher level Intuit, which actually they also, I don't believe, offer much for New Hampshire e-filing still.
But that really is prohibitive from just randomly, not randomly, but sort of planning to change for that reason alone.
um it's just it's a lot to change vendors financially, the time costs, and yeah, it's just, it's a bigger deal.
It's a big deal.
Understood.
Thank you.
I don't see any other hand, so I don't want to ask the next witness, actually a sponsor, Representative Alexander.
Representative Alexander.
I don't see him on.
Okay, then the next is from the DRA, Carolyn Lear.
Hello, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
Carolyn Lear, Assistant Commissioner at the New Hampshire Department of Revenue.
Mr.
Chickering did a lovely job explaining how things work here at the DRA, so I won't repeat anything that he's already explained about how sort of e-filing works currently.
I just want to say that the Department of Revenue is very much in favor of e-filing.
E-filing is good for the department.
E-filed returns are certainly easier to process, but we don't take a position on mandated e-filing.
We're happy to accept returns and money however they come in, and we just don't take a position on mandating the e-filing.
You all received a fiscal note quick guide from us on this bill, which sort of explains our position on the revenue impact.
As you heard from Mr.
Chickering, we have a staff that's responsible for approving vendors to e-file with the department.
That staff is currently maybe one, one and a half people.
And how that process works is if a vendor wants to e-file New Hampshire returns or to facilitate the e-filing of New Hampshire returns, they have to sort of prove to us that the data is going to come through in an accurate way that's digestible by our computer systems, to put it quite simply.
But the work of that group doesn't really stop there because every filing season, there are changes to New Hampshire forms.
So it's communicating back and forth with each of the vendors to sort of communicate those changes and make sure that they effectuate those changes on their end properly.
And then every filing season there are always issues.
A good example is a couple years ago, one of the larger vendors who files a great proportion of the electronic business tax returns in New Hampshire.
The returns were coming through with the incorrect FEIN.
This was an issue with partnerships because in New Hampshire, we require partnerships to use an FEIN, not the social of their members.
So the returns were coming through with the wrong FEIN.
And it was a huge issue for us because we couldn't post the returns to the correct taxpayer account without the correct FEIN.
And we worked quite extensively with the vendor to make sure they fixed that issue.
So those are the sorts of things, the work that might increase with increased e-filing.
But of course, that work is going to be offset by a loss of manual work, primarily opening mail.
That is really the manual part for us of receiving a paper return.
As you heard, opening and unstapling paper returns is a lot of work.
The scanning isn't a ton of work because we sort of do those in stacks.
You take the stack of returns, put them on the machine, and they just feed through and scan.
And we don't do a ton of manual data entry because our paper returns are scanned and then we have an optical recognition system that actually pulls the data off the return.
So we're not doing a ton of data entry, but certainly the work of opening all that mail manually would substantially decrease if e-filing were to be mandated and thus our proportion of e-filed returns were to increase.
You have the fiscal note quick guide.
I did do a bit of research into other states' statutes, and I did highlight Thank you.
to increase.
You have the fiscal note quick guide.
I did do a bit of research into other states' statutes and I did highlight a few things that you might want to consider if you were to go forward with this bill.
Otherwise, I'm just happy to answer any of your questions.
Representative Almi has her hand up.
Representative Almi, you have a question.
Oh dear, the phone is ringing in the background, ignore it.
I did have the same kinds of questions about this related to the vendors, how hard it's going to be to incorporate this and whether they're going to put the price into what they charge the CPAs.
I use a CPA that did not like being in a firm, which she had started actually.
And she works herself.
She just moved to Colorado last year and she's still doing New Hampshire taxes for people.
I don't actually know if she does businesses still, but her firm does, the one she started.
And she does quite a few tax returns and some pretty complicated ones and does them very well.
And she was deliriously happy when you put IND out as e-filing.
But I do worry about whether there's a real issue in terms of vendors charging more for the entire package, if that's the way it would work, or putting an add-on for New Hampshire and making that an option in other states tax packages.
But I also am worried about the effective date.
I do know it takes quite a long time to process the changes each year and get them ready for the software vendors so that they can get the software to the CPAs so that they can provide next year's tax returns.
And I'm not sure whether making it effective in this July works, or is that one of your recommendations?
And I am very sorry that I have not read the quick note yet.
Thank you, Representative, for the question.
I'll just say I'm not concerned about the work required of us to implement more e-filing.
I think, like I said, we get more work in one area, but we lose it in another.
Of course, we don't receive any information about what the vendors are charging for their product.
And so I really couldn't speak to what would happen with prices.
I did not include a recommendation in my fiscal note quick hide about the effective date, but I did include a recommendation that perhaps you add or modify sort of the requirement to indicate that it only applies to returns that are available for e-filing.
And I think that might remedy the timing issue a bit.
Because if a vendor hasn't had the time to go through the process yet with the department, then it would not be an issue of the vendor refusing to e-file, but just an issue of them not having made it available yet.
And I think that might remedy that concern.
Because I agree, it will take some time for vendors to establish that relationship with the department and get the returns flowing to us, particularly because they do their work on a tax year.
So if you miss the tax year, it's really going to be working towards the next tax year to get e-filing up and running.
Thank you.
Do you think that that's a better way to handle than to simply make it effective a year later?
Because that, what you're talking about, that that's a better way to handle this than to simply make it effective the year a year later because that what you're talking about i think would be putting a temporary exemption in forever that's true i think um one of the other things that i believe you address by saying returns that are available for e-filing is you address the concern about old years, right?
We accept amended returns.
Pretty much any year you want to file will at least take in the return, even if it's out of statute, and process it.
But vendors are not going to want to go back and make their 2011 return e-fileable.
It just wouldn't be efficient because they might only receive one or two amended returns for those old years ever.
So that's another concern that the recommendation addresses.
Thank you.
Okay, Representative Ainge, do you have a question?
Okay, I'm unmuted.
Yeah, I wonder if you could give us a sense, maybe there have to be categories of the volume we're talking about.
What proportion of returns are now e-filed?
And looking forward, if this mandate applied to those that are filing more than, what is it, 25, what would be the change in that volume can you give us a sense of that or are we talking about big complex returns mostly or is it a full range of returns that would have to be you filed now or there would be e-filed you for the question, Representative.
I did pull some stats from fiscal year 20.
Meals and rentals, I pulled meals and rentals, IND, and business returns.
For meals and rentals, we receive about 30,000 returns a year, or received 30,000 returns in that fiscal year.
And 91% of those returns were electronically filed.
I think the reason you see that is because in order to get the 3% commission under the M&R tax, operators have to e-file.
For interest in dividends tax, it's 66,000 returns and about 71% were e-filed and 29% were filed in paper.
I think interest in dividends tax returns are relatively easy.
You know, there are one or two pages, not a lot of information on them.
So I think vendors have been particularly willing to do those returns for New Hampshire to e-file them.
I'm not sure I can answer the question for you about whether e-filing would increase the IND e-filing percentage.
I'm not sure why that 29% isn't e-filing.
For business taxes, for fiscal year 20, we had about 77,000 returns, and it was almost 50-50 paper and e-file.
And so I really think that business taxes is the place where you would see the largest swing in e-filing.
Because one, there's the most sort of ground to cover there with only 50% being e-filed.
And I can only speak anecdotally about why it's so low with business taxes, but I do think at least anecdotally, it does relate to sort of the uniqueness and complexity of the New Hampshire return and why those are getting mailed.
Thank you.
All right.
Mr.
Chik, do you want to comment?
Well, thank you.
I just wanted to respond briefly.
I know representative Almey has some concerns and Representative Ames, but I just wanted to mention that or just share my experiences with pricing and the cost associated with it.
And I'm happy to speak offline anytime.
So you guys are welcome to reach out to me if you have more concerns and you need more explanations or anything I can offer.
But as e-file has evolved over the years and more and more states either required it or became available because of the ease of their laws and piggybacking off federal returns, I've never seen my vendor or any vendor say, oh, well now, now that Vermont is offering e-filing, we're increasing our fees by X amount of dollars.
I just have not seen that in my experience.
Usually it's just the federal package and then the state package.
So I wanted to share that.
It hasn't been my experience that it'll be an increase in cost if this bill were to say New Hampshire is going to be requiring e-filing.
And my guess is if this legislation were to pass, it would have an effective date for years beginning on or after a certain date, which would most likely be the next calendar year or however the process works in legislation, which I'm not quite as familiar with.
So I don't think it would be anything that were a bomb is dropped on all these practitioners all of a sudden, and they're sort of left out in the cold and not knowing what to do.
So I wanted to share that.
And Representative Ames, I know the I think the word mandate can be very scary in a sense versus saying requiring.
But I do think it's important for us to consider an opt out if you don't have the technological capabilities and or if you just don't want to e-file same thing with IRS rules IRS rules if you can't file return by paper you can opt out so I don't see why we can't add that to this bill that pretty much there's a requirement to do it we're requiring requiring to do at least 25, but even if you're doing more than 25 and you're having and you do have some concerns about being able to effectively e-file, then there should be a check the box form that's easily approved.
So thank you.
I just wanted to add address those concerns.
Okay.
Representative Elliott, you have a question?
Yes.
It's for Mr.
Chickeree.
Can you hear me?
Yes, sir.
But he answered the question.
But the question was going to be, don't you believe, as I do, that one of the drawbacks of this bill is that the increased costs, whatever they are, will definitely be passed on to the consumer.
Now your answer to the question is, no, you don't think that's going to happen.
But if I were a gambling man, I'll bet you 100 bucks bucks to a dollar that it is going to happen.
Thank you for answering my question.
You're welcome.
I would actually look at it the other way.
It costs me and my firm more time to physically print the return, to put sign here stickers on it to pay postageage, to mail to the client, for them to spend time to sign and mail and write a checkout versus if e-filing capabilities were in place, the process and time spent is much faster.
So I do not believe there would be additional costs that would be passed on.
At least in my firm, there wouldn't be.
I don't know if anyone else would justify that as a reason for doing so, but I don't see it.
I think it takes more time and cost to do it by hand.
I'm sorry that we disagree strongly.
Representative John Jigdon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This question is for Carolyn Lear.
I was wondering, can we get a list of the vendors, the tax vendors who you're currently working with?
And I wonder whether listing, and maybe you already have this on the state website, a list of those vendors that you do work electronically with.
Because not only would it be informative, but it might actually cause other vendors to say, hey, maybe we should work electronically.
Because I'll tell you, I find it annoying when I get to that point with TurboTax, for instance.
And again, I'm just an individual filing my own stuff that I now have to print it out and send it in when all I could have done is just click the button and been done.
So I guess, do you list the vendors?
And if not, could you list the vendors on the state website that you currently work with?
Thank you for the question, Representative.
Yes, we do list the vendors that are currently approved and working with us for e-file on our website.
I will send the link to Jennifer and ask that she circulate it to the committee.
But yes, it's posted on our website, primarily so that folks can know.
We think of it more as a compliance tool so that if you're curious, if your vendor is legitimately working with this state, you could identify that on the website.
We think of it less as a sort of consumer, I guess, push tool as more of an ability to check.
Thank you.
Representative Urali.
There it goes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I actually contacted my accountant regarding this and their comment was there's only two things that they have to file up.
One would be for our dupe-eyed paper.
One is the low-income tax rebate, and the other one is the business profits tax.
Everything else they do for either mass or the federal government is done electronically.
I ask them what the cost would be if they went all electronic.
There would be no increase.
It would most likely be a decrease in cost because they don't have to do any more work.
They type it on the computer, they push a button, and it's gone.
It's gone.
Okay, was that a question or a statement?
That was a question.
Would you believe?
Thank you.
Who wants to respond to that?
Seeing none, Representative for both Mr.
Chickering and Ms.
Lear.
If I'm understanding this correctly, the purpose or motive of the requested legislation is to put leverage on a certain group of vendors, I don't know if they're a minority or majority, to move into the current world.
But the current status as I am getting it is that DRA does accept e-filing, encourages e-filing, but they're taking no position on mandating e-filing.
And I just wonder whether the problem is not as large as the bill makes it look like.
So, for example, nothing in this bill defines tax returns, which tax returns we're focusing on.
I know we're amending 21J13D.
I haven't looked at that, so I don't know whether it's more limited in prior statutory language.
But should this be more narrowly focused to address to the very specific problem that Mr.
Chickering has identified, which seems to be the BPT-BET?
Anybody want to respond to that?
Mr.
Chair, this is Carolyn Lear from the Department of Revenue.
I think you've accurately described the department's position on the legislation.
I do agree with you.
And if you have the fiscal note quick guide in front of you, there's a comment.
I believe this statute or the bill uses the phrase authorized tax document.
And I do think that could use a definition, but I won't speak to whether or not the bill's sponsor could still achieve their goal with limiting it to business taxes.
I think either the sponsor or Mr.
Chickering could speak to that.
Okay.
Mr.
Chickering, did you want to respond?
Sure.
Yeah.
Representative Spilsbury, hopefully this helps address or answer some questions.
So as far as saying a business profits tax return and a business enterprise tax return, Carolyn can also help me explain this as well.
As far as business profits tax returns, there's essentially five different ones for each type of business entity.
if you're a sole proprietor, there's what's called an NH-1040 business profits tax return that has different rules and other business profits tax returns.
If you're a single member LLC, that's a multi-member LLC, you default to be a partnership, then you file a form NH-1065, which is a business profits tax return.
So it goes down the line, there's an NH-1120 business, so there's all different types of business profits returns that get prepared.
Similarly, for the BET, there's a few different types, but Carolyn could probably help me with that as well but there's there's many returns that all have a little bit different nuances and all have to have different types of tax treatments as they go through the process so it's i don't know if i'm answering your question but it's not just sort of simply of returns.
There's many, many different and they all flow into the business tax summary return when they get submitted to the Department of Revenue.
And I don't know if that answers your question, Representative Spilsbury.
I think it answers in part from one direction, which is to say there's a multitude of different forms and returns relating to business tax.
But it doesn't answer the question from the other perspective, which is using a broad term like one authorized tax document sweeps in how many other kinds of returns.
Understood.
Yeah, when I initially had worked on, worked with Representative Gunstey on this legislation, I had spelled out all the types of returns that it does, that it would address, business profits, taxes for, you know, partnerships, for sole proprietorships, for corporations.
So they were spelled out and they can be spelled out or the term tax returns covers them in a sense with a broad brush, but certainly that's something that can be worked on and defined better.
So that would, hopefully that helps answer the question.
So, and I did want to mention representative Eulery, your comment on you would talk to your accounting firm and it sounded to me, they had said there would really be no cost involved on their end that they would pass on to consumers that it's just a matter of increasing efficiencies like i'll i'll do 100 100 something new hampshire returns every year and the process just stops where you're sort of so efficient with all the other states and then your own home state becomes a project to get the returns completed As I keep keep reiterating the whole process to get a paper file return done and processed can be a nightmare.
So thank you.
Can I just quickly follow up to ask Ms.
Lear to also address my question.
Carolyn.
Just to make sure I understand, your question is whether the, as worded, the statute scoops in a lot more than the target.
Whether we need a limiting definition for the terms, tax returns, or one authorized tax document?
I think the answer is yes, for sure.
I would encourage you to take a look at the fiscal note quick guide.
I think one of our concerns is making sure that the only requirement is on forms that are capable of being e-filed, meaning forms that we accept via e-file currently.
Because, for example, I think as drafted, this would capture the railroad tax.
And the railroad tax is a very small tax that, you know, a handful of railroads pay.
And we don't accept those e-filed currently.
We will accept them via e-file when we roll out the next portion of our new Granite Tax Connect online web portal, but currently we don't accept those electronically.
So we want to make sure that you're not mandating that folks file something electronically that we can't yet accept electronically.
So I think there are examples where this is probably scooping in other tax types unintentionally, for sure.
I'll defer to, again, to this bill sponsor as to what the intended target was but I think it likely wasn't examples like the railroad tax thank you that gets directly to my question I appreciate it okay represent thank you mr.
chairman on I.
I think this is mostly to Ms.
Lear.
The interest in dividends tax is frequently prepared still by the person, the individual that's paying it because it's just, it comes pretty much straight from your federal return.
Or it is prepared in a lot of cases, and I believe Granite United Way helps set these up in some places.
Ours are done through our senior centers.
Individuals who are volunteers get a short course in how to fill these things out, and they are brought to the senior center every year, and the people wait while it gets done.
This year it's going to be done in a parking lot.
But these are volunteers.
They aren't really trained tax people, except very briefly, I think.
And they must also, it had never occurred to me that they must be doing the low and median moderate income property tax relief forms, which when that was started, were extremely complex.
I hope they've been simplified.
But it was the town clerks who had to help people fill them out.
And so a lot of them didn't even get filled out.
And that is also something that someone who is eligible for low and moderate income property tax relief is usually not going to have an accountant.
So I wanted to ask on if you thought there's that one, there's the railroad tax, there's a whole other of these, whether we ought to just specify the business taxes as possibly being something that this would be done with.
And anybody paying the business taxes may well be paying the interest and dividends tax.
They would automatically, I think, he filed that one.
And we also, we already solved the rooms and meals when we put in the 3% rebate.
Let her answer that.
Mrs.
Carolyn?
Thank you, Representative Almi.
I don't know the answer to whether or not the VITA clinics, whether they're currently, the VITA clinics and also I think AARP does some free tax prep clinics for both the IND tax and the low and moderate program.
And I apologize.
I don't know off the top of my head whether they are e-filing those returns or whether they're printing them and sending them with the constituent.
However, I think there may be some space within the statute to maybe sort of carve out an exemption there if you were so inclined.
And as far as limiting this to just the business taxes, I mean, I think you certainly could do that.
We don't take a position on whether mandated e-filing is a good or bad thing, so I won't advise you to whether that is a good or bad idea, but I think that would certainly be a way to target this a little more narrowly.
Okay, I'm going to limit this now to Representative Gonski.
Representative Gonski?
uh gunski you want to unmute yes good morning sorry my audio was cutting out i could you repeat that?
Hello?
Yes.
I'm recognizing you, you had your hand raised.
Okay, yes.
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
The audio is in and out on my computer.
I'm not sure if I have some internet issues.
I am sending my testimony into the committee.
And the testimony I've highlighted actual the actual returns and that information was provided to OLS when this was drawn up it just wasn't actually included so it specifies exactly the returns that that Mr.
Chickering was was addressing.
okay and we will be having a work session on bills next week.
And this bill will be included in that.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
All right.
Mr.
Chickering, you have one final comment?
Yes.
I just want to assess, help Representative Almi with her concern regarding preparers like volunteers who may be helping people.
there's a definition or there will be a definition, if this is as introduced, that defines a tax return preparer.
It says means a person repairs any New Hampshire state tax return or claim for refund for compensation.
So these are VITA people helping at a retirement home, helping people file interest in dividends tax return.
It does not apply to them because they're not doing it for compensation.
Okay.
I don't see any more hands.
I have a question.
Oh, represent Tucker.
Yes, I wanted to ask Ms.
Lear what the effect would be if this were delayed for a year while all these different facets were looked into and possible amendments made and so forth.
Is there any particular rush to get this through?
So like I testified to, the department doesn't really take a position on whether we need to mandate e-file or not.
So similarly, we wouldn't take a position on delaying it a year either.
From our perspective, we are happy to continue to accept paper returns for so long as the legislature would like us to do that.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hold on one second.
I don't see any more hands.
Okay, hold on one second.
One second.
Major, there is a, Kevin Kennedy as an attendee has his hand up.
Okay.
Before I do that, let me just finish reading the blue sheet.
The blue sheet has aaf has an Eric representing himself from the public who opposes this and Representative Alexander who is a co-sponsor and he said Mr.
Ho.
Kevin Kennedy again, and I've just unmuted him.
If you'd like to say.
Mr.
Kennedy.
Thank you very much.
As I mentioned before, I'm a CPA here in New Hampshire.
I'm also on the Board of Trustees for the Hampshire Society of CPAs, and I'm-chair of the Tax and Legislation Committee.
Generally speaking, with the conversations I've had with my peers in these committees, we're not taking a position in favor or against this particular bill.
Certainly, I think we all understand the pros and cons associated with having electronic filing and the efficiency that comes with that.
A couple of items to note relative to this bill.
This bill is, of course, for tax practitioners or people who receive compensation.
So individuals who are doing their own returns on TurboTax, this wouldn't apply to them as far as I understand the bill.
So as an item of clarity, I think that's important to note that this doesn't mandate software companies requiring them to have e-file availability for anybody who uses their software, only that practitioners who do 25 or more have to use electronic filing.
Relative to the opt-out options that were discussed, I think perhaps in terms of opt-out, having a practitioner opt-out, if that ability is there, I'm not sure if that might defeat the purpose of the bill.
Again, not that we're opposed or against, but if the software company simply goes, well, you can opt out.
So we're not going to, we're not going to put New Hampshire electronic filing in our software, then that might defeat it.
I think a better word for practitioners would be filing for an exemption, which basically means they can submit to the DRA why doing electronic filing in their situation is problematic.
I know this puts more burden on the DRA, but perhaps that would be a compromise relative to providing practitioners some ability.
As the comments to me from the people in the society and the committee, one of the concerns was having the taxpayer the ability to opt out.
Several states have a form that allow the taxpayer to sign and tell the practitioner, I don't want to electronically file.
And as such, here's a document releasing you of the responsibility to file my return.
And I think that's a very, if this bill is put into place, that would be a very important piece of it.
If not specifically stated, then somehow guidance relative to when the DRA comes out with the rules associated with this bill.
A lot of older taxpayers are concerned about electronic filing.
They like that paper copy, you know, mailing it in, getting a check mailed back to them.
And this word mandate can be a little bit spooky for folks.
And the other provision I think that we would like is some concern about relief from penalties associated with not filing.
I certainly had situations where I've tried to file things like a federal return, and there have been glitches along the way, and the return simply had to be manually filed.
So some sort of relief, and again, whether or not this is simply guidance in the bill or specifically stated relief that practitioners can be provided penalty for relief for reasonable cause.
And maybe that's because there was a medical condition, maybe COVID, maybe technical glitches, maybe because their software, it's a little tricky because we're trying to get the software vendors in place here, but maybe they simply, their software vendor simply hasn't been able to get their software in place for it.
But some relief for practitioners so that they aren't necessarily unduly hit with penalties.
And I think that's it.
We also, I think we also support what the DRA's comments were about making sure that it only mandates returns that the DRA is actually set up to accept electronically.
And I believe that's all my comments.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mr.
Kennedy.
Anybody else wants to testify for or against hospital 528?
I don't see any.
So I'm going to close the public hearing on house bill 528.
Thank you.
Close the public hearing on House Bill 528.
Okay, we're going to do a test to see if our system is up.
So what do you want us to do?
So I'm going to mute your computers and turn your speakers on.
I'll just put the volume all the way down.
your computers and turn your speakers on Thank you.
Gracias.
Thank you.
you want to all right Mr.
Chairman It's going to be a test in one, two, Mr.
Chairman, you want to?
Testing, one, two, three.
E a Thank you.
Okay.
We're going to start with the next hearing.
I'm opening here on House Bill 134, repealing certain inactive dedicated funds.
And the prime sponsor is Representative Major.
Representative Major.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This bill is a result of a joint committee that's been in existence for a number of years.
And they do a five year rotation.
One year they'll look at about a half a dozen agencies, all the dedicated funds associated with that.
Next year they'll do five other different agencies.
And every year the joint on Dedicated Fund looks at and tries to identify those funds that are inactive or no longer needed.
And we start off the year by asking the Administrative Services to give us a list of all the dedicated funds that have no, that have no, had no activity.
And then we'll bring in the agencies and ask them, since there's been no activities, are these dedicated funds mated and why?
That's one area we look at.
Then we looked at all the dedicated funds on a group of, say, five agencies, and we review them with the agencies to see if any of these can be removed or any of them could be modified.
And we have over a couple hundred dedicated funds.
Over the last few years, we've eliminated probably close to a hundred dedicated funds are no longer necessary and they no longer have to be carried on the books.
This legislation is the result of what we did this past year and Representative Almi is going to verify that we have the dedicated funds that we agreed on as part of this legislation.
This legislation also covers two years because last year's bill as a result of a pandemic didn't get done.
It was essentially tabled because it wasn't considered that important.
So now we're dealing with this two years worth of joint committee study.
To look at the bill, line on the first page, line one through seven eliminates four dedicated funds from the post-secondary education commission storage after we did all the interrogation and mutually agreed it's not needed anymore.
But in section 2, line 8 through 11, we find out that there's a couple funds that should have been listed.
So lines 8 through 11 puts these two funds into a dedicated fund, money deposit and forest improvement fund, and money deposit and forest protection personal training fund.
To categorize these as dedicated funds to be reviewed on a five-year cycle.
Section three was primarily cleanup.
Some of these dedicated funds needed the legislative language Thank you.
Section 3 was primarily cleanup.
Some of these dedicated funds needed the legislative language to go along with them, so the intent of the dedicated funds is represented.
Section 3 does that.
Section 5, which starts on line 20, is also a clean up in legislation that's required to go on those dedicated funds.
Section 6 is the balance of public interest payment fund lapsed to the Public Utility Commission.
Section 7 repeals two funds on the meat inspection fund.
Section 8 clarify the reference to the fund is removed and it cleans up the legislation.
Section 9 is the John Winnett Memorial Special Account.
Essentially, it has been agreed that it is no longer required.
Section 10 reveals the Office of Professional Licenses for certain licenses relative to 612-JVD8 relative to the year 4 reporting requirements for the Office of professional licenses and certification that's revealed.
Section 11 starting on line 34 also applies the office of professional licenses.
And And we had to amend that so the intent of this fund was qualified.
Representative Alney will follow me and further explain.
explain.
Senator Geider who was on this?
Senator Geider was a member of the Dedicated Fund.
So there's a committee.
Who was made up the committee?
Right.
Who made up the committee?
I was Representative Alney, myself.
Representative Ober was either a member or an alternate.
And there was another alternate from the House, Senator Gray, Senator Geider, Senator, I think her what was the third senator that made up that committee.
Okay.
Questions?
I have a question.
Representative, Major, Representative Maynes.
Your hands.
Yeah.
By the way, Representative Ames, it's very hard to hear you.
So my question is simply, can you tell us, or maybe Representative Ames will be doing this, what money is involved in these funds and where it's going.
For example, the legislation says that the, provides that the payphone fund will lapse to the Public Utilities Commission.
So apparently there's some money there.
And what kind of money are we talking about?
And then there are a couple of funds that are just repealed i don't see anything about what happens to the money and maybe there's no money but can you sort of speak to this question of the realities of the situation when we abolish a dedicated fund and there's funds in it usually it goes and lapses into the general fund.
Less specified.
There are times that there may be two different dedicated funds, they do almost the same thing.
And we'll abolish one and move the funds into the other dedicated fund.
It depends on what it is.
A number of times there have been no funds, and it's just been sitting there on the books.
Representative Ames, you all said it?
Well, I just was trying to get a sense of magnitude, and I didn't get that.
Representative Almey.
I haven't recognized her yet.
The questions, are you all set, Representative Vames?
Yes, I am, thank you.
Okay, Representative Vames, you're recognized.
Thank you.
These get pretty complex and I was trying to find the PUC report.
But I wanted first to point out this thing is the, what I call a telephone book.
It is all the dedicated funds accounting for the state.
We've been doing it now for a number of years, but nobody was reading it, so particularly the committees that should be in charge of these funds, and so we decided that we would set up this committee.
Representative Walner was also on it, and to my surprise, she showed up quite a lot because she was learning things from finance.
She was learning things about the dedicated funds that they hadn't bothered to look at.
So, now I'm in representative Major has explained a lot of this, but in 2019, we deleted three funds that are no longer useful and adjusted their language where necessary, because sometimes they're related to legislative language elsewhere, but that language refers back to the dedicated funds.
So if we repeal it, there's a problem.
That was true in particular for the one of these, sorry, I'm dealing with two years versions of the bill plus it was true in particular for the public interest pay fund the It was true in particular for the public interest pay fund.
The public interest pay fund had, I think, about $20,000 in it.
And since it was under the PUC, we defaulted it to the PUC, relapsed it to the PUC.
Most of them had absolutely nothing in them.
It had been transferred to another fund already and it was just sitting there complicating things.
The meat inspection program Fund was one of those.
It was repealed.
And the John G.
Winant fund had, I think, a very small amount of money left in it.
It was lapsed to the general fund.
that built that, oh no, yes, it was built, it built that lovely statue that is in front of the State Library now of John Winant, who was governor long ago and became very important nationally when he served very capably as an ambassador during World War II in Britain.
That one, we had to revise Ola language so that there would be no more building considered, but we did O.
So we've left the commission, but not the money in existence so that if sometime in the future they need to acquire more money from contributions and fix the statute, that it could be done.
This was the prime author of the original bill was Representative Shurtleff.
And I got the language from him for this.
on with the animal abuse and treatment fund had been set up on the Animal Abuse and Treatment Fund had been set up.
Oh, no, sorry.
Alcohol Abuse and Prevention Treatment Fund, Section 3.
On that, the money from that in the budget was taken away to be used for the Medicaid Enhancement Program, which Granite State Health Protection Program, I think it's called now.
But nothing was done to the language for the fund itself.
and there was the statutory reference was wrong.
And it didn't allow for the fact that the fund money was replaced in the budget by a two-year payment to the alcohol fund to continue operating.
And it was replaced in the statute, sending it to HHS for the Medicaid prevention.
And the idea was this was supposed to be two years.
So we adjusted the language back so that it does do that.
But then there is still a special language for those two years of the current budget sending the actual money over to the Medicaid Enhancement Program.
And the public interest pay funds was set up was set up by a representative who is not with us, I believe, anymore.
Because there were orphaned phones sitting in different parts of the state.
He had one in his district.
It's the only one that actually came into the program.
And the PUC, the utilities that dealt with telephone service were having to pay into this fund, not very much money.
It only amounted to about $20,000.
And the fund was not being used.
We couldn't even find out whether that particular fund still existed.
So we eliminated the program, and we lapsed that money to the PUC, which was in charge of it.
And I think there was a complicated issue with the Office of Professional Licensure and Certification.
we discovered that it had been set up and that it had removed all the fees to control by the head of the office.
And that we ought to stick it in as part of this program of review.
And we set it up for review for last year.
The program has had three different, it was started three years ago now, two and a half, and it has had three heads since then.
They kept on retiring or quitting.
And it now has an extremely capable head.
But at the time that they came in, they came in and they told us, look, we realize now that we are in chaos and we just asked for a performance audit.
And we last year added to that performance audit a financial audit, which LBAO said they could do easily at the same time.
That is coming out very shortly now.
But they said, will you please do us next year when we're more capable of responding?
And we agreed to that.
So this language, it repeals what we put into the statute, putting them in in year four, and it moves them to year five.
That's all it does.
And they will be in the fifth year of the cycle.
so they will be coming in at that point.
I think they're going to be a lot more organized than they are now.
There's a bill over in the Senate to send to us that will be dealing with the language for the fees that this new director had developed, which ended up on the cutting room floor partly because of us last time because we had no idea what it was about.
So that's, I think, just about everything in there.
If anybody has any specific questions, I can...
Representative South Park, you're right, very nice.
Am I unmuted?
Yes, sir.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for taking my question, really a comment.
I just wanted to appreciate Chairman Major and Representative Almi for their dedication, reviewing the dedicated funds, because I think their diligence, their long-term commitment, This is something important that they've really stuck with for a long time.
So I just wanted that noted.
Thank you.
David Daley- Thanks chairman.
David Daley- Dedicated fun issue as a nightmare.
as was represented Almy showed you a huge book, hundreds of pages of dedicated funds.
They hadn't been looked at.
We set up a process for over a five year period and we review all of them.
And then we've been able to reduce the size of the book by getting rid of dedicated funds that are no longer necessary.
But when we look at them, we find the legislation to back this up is wrong.
It's got to be fixed.
And a whole bunch of them.
That's why I call it a nightmare.
If you love to handle nightmares, volunteer to be on the Joint Committee of Dedicated Friends.
Representative Major, this Joint Committee continues, right?
Yes.
Have appointments been made yet for this term?
Letters just came out.
They just came out, okay.
And will it be delayed until it's bandwidth?
Until there is, because right now it's only five.
What do you anticipate?
That it will start in the summer?
I have no idea.
We may say go to the Department of Safety or Highway or some other who has a zone and ask if you can use this.
Thank you.
But we have to have something that the public has access to.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Amami?
The setup that we developed was that in August, all of the departments that are up for review and several that promised to get back to us about things that education and health and human services last time had a lot of loose ends attached to them that we don't have answers for back yet because of the COVID.
But they have to get everything by mid August to the comptroller's office, which is the one that's overseeing this.
And then we, on Representative Major, will set up dates for us to meet.
And if we're really lucky, maybe we can meet in person by that time and maybe not.
But we did meet virtually last time and it didn't work too badly.
So the other thing is that sometime in the next couple of months, Representative Major is going to have to talk to the comptroller's office about getting after all of those agencies and reminding them that they're due.
They're getting used to it.
It's getting easier for us to work because of that.
I did want to mention that the book is up on the CAFR website, the one that has the monthly revenue focus and the CAFR for the DAS.
And it's somewhat easier to search that than it is to get a copy of the book that they don't make too many copies of.
But you have to be a little creative in looking at the names of the dedicated funds, because sometimes they're referred to differently in one place than another.
And we will have bills, especially second committee bills, that have dedicated fund effects in them.
And it's really helpful to look up the accounting for those and the explanation that is in before we do the hearing.
And the explanations from the last two years.
It took us a while to learn how to do this, but the explanations from the last two years, I think are pretty good.
But we ran into a number of agencies that just didn't have proper explanations and we've been cleaning it up as we go.
thank you jenny is there anyone else out there no actually there's no attendees right now there's no attendees okay okay okay with that eric Eric Rathborn, signed up on the school, and Thindra Guida is in support.
That's what we have.
So without any other questions from the committee, I'm going to adjourn the meeting on House Bill 134.
you know, this sound quality is just like this morning, all that echoing.
Can you tell from there?
Yeah, I heard it.
I heard it.
Oh, okay.
Just wanted to make sure.
Thank you.
I'm turning the chair back over.
This has been quite a morning.
I was hoping that we would have had time to exec a few bills.
We got 25 minutes.
We're done with the morning bills.
Right.
The next public hearing starts at one o'clock.
So we could exec some bills.
So hold on.
I was in Almey has had her caucus review the bills that we heard on the 28th of January, and I reviewed the bills with the Republican caucus.
There's three bills that both committees agree could be exact.
One is House Bill 281.
And I'll have to pull it out.
House Bill 281 is relative to the tax expenditure report and relative to delaying the enactment of single sales factor under the business profits and business enterprise tax.
This is Representative Bromley's bill.
It looks like both caucuses are ready to exist.
So why don't I go into executive session on House Bill 281-, Representative Bromney.
I'd like to make a motion to pass on House Bill 281.
I'd like to second that.
Representative Bromney.
And Representative Ames.
Chamber.
Representative Bromley.
Yes, just real quick.
This bill does three things.
It modifies one of the it delays implementation of single sales factor until tax periods ending on or after December 31st of 2026.
And it creates or basically amends and it creates an apportionment committee going forward, a joint committee with the Senate to monitor progress on where we are with the other tax changes that have occurred.
So market-based sourcing specifically.
So those are the three things it does.
The reasons we're doing that are especially the delay in the implementation date of single sales factor is that we need to have some time to measure the impact of market based sourcing.
We want to make sure market based sourcing increases revenue from service businesses out of state serving clients in New Hampshire.
Remember, our DRA has to find these people out there.
It may take longer than a year to do.
We want to create a solid baseline to measure our moving forward with single sales factor.
and given that so many of our top taxpayers manufacture things that are sold out of state, we do have some concern that this may be a major hit in our revenues.
We don't know yet.
So we want to delay this until we know better.
And all I'll say is that other states have done this.
That number grows.
But other states have income tax, personal income tax, sales tax, other things to buffer an error.
And if we make a mistake with this one, we could have a major problem.
And as I mentioned the other day, I heard from the Business Industry Association and their membership, which is pretty large membership, they're the biggest association of this kind in the state, are split on this, which means that they're probably winners and losers here.
we just don't know you know the winners outnumber the losers on this one so but those are my comments on this I hope we all support OTP on this.
Representative Ames has a question or a comment.
I think it's a comment at this stage.
Can, I'm, can you hear me?
Yes.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, I was just speaking on this motion, and I do support what to pass.
And Representative Abrami has stated well the basic considerations.
It's a very, very important bill.
It's very important that we delay what is now in statute for the startup of single sales factor.
We're going too fast into something that we don't understand.
So allowing a little extra time so that we can look at it, get good information from DRA and know exactly what we're headed into and maybe modify if that's what the information says to us.
Makes all the sense in the world.
So I hope that we will vote for what to pass on this.
Chair, can I make another comment?
Representative Brodney.
Remember that the Senate flipped us into the last budget, the compromise budget.
They also created a committee, a joint committee for members from the House, three members from the Senate that was supposed to be twice and then voted last November 2020 on whether or not the single sales factor.
And I think Representative Valenegade reiterated when we talked about this last, that we got guidance when we met, it was almost like they appeased us a bit by putting this clause in this statute.
But we were told then that that language was constitutional.
Come came November, last November, when we're trying to get that committee together, we learned that that language wasn't constitutional.
We had the votes to stop it then.
It was for House because our position as a committee for the new members was to slow this down.
And we never really had a proper hearing on this here in the House, which kind of upsets us, but we can get beyond that.
But we had the chance to slow it down.
But so that what they put in the legislation to give us a trigger to slow it down disappeared.
So it became law.
And again, it was buried in the budget.
And HB4, it was not HB2 because HB2 was vetoed, became HB4.
And that's the story.
So again, as a committee, we never had proper hearings on this.
We want to know why the Senate and why the governor thought this was a great idea to do now.
That's all I want to know.
But when we had the hearing on this bill, no one showed up, really, to ask those questions, ask ask us or at least explain to us why we should do this now.
So those are my comments.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Representative Elmer.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I think Representative Ames might have been going to say the same thing.
But as far as we can determine, there was never really a hearing in the Senate either.
This was put in HB 4 as something that without which the budget would not pass.
And I do not think that there was a hearing even in the Senate, even on a consolidated bill that included this.
so there's been no chance for the businesses in the BIA, for instance, that seem to be opposed to it, to come forward and talk.
We were hoping they would come forward when we did those two listening sessions, hearings, in the special seven-person committee.
But as I recall, mostly what we got was overviews, which included some very strong warnings against going forward with this before knowing much about what it was going to do.
So we are, I think, going to have to make, if we pass this to the Senate, we are going to need to talk with them about it a lot more clearly than has been done so far.
But it is, as Representative Ames and Representative Abrami said, it is really, really incredibly important to our revenues.
It is possible that we could end up getting rid of a large part of the BET tax, BP tax that we depend on.
Any further questions or comments?
Say none.
Then I'll have the clerk follow the motion of ought to pass.
Bill HB 281, up to pass is the motion.
Let's begin with Representative Abrami.
Yes.
Subbing for Representative Griffin is Representative Charles Melvin.
Representative Ulrich.
Yes.
Representative Ober.
Representative Ulrich.
Yes.
Representative Ober.
Clerk, Representative Berstein votes yes.
Representative Doucette.
Yes.
Representative Elliott.
Representative Janigian.
Yes.
Representative Nunez.
Thank you.
Representative Tudor has to be on video.
Representative Tudor, turn on your...
There you go.
And then unmute yourself.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And who else?
Representative Almy.
Yes.
Representative Ames.
Representative Southworth.
Yes.
Representative Ames.
Representative Southworth.
Yes.
Representative Malloy.
Representative Schamburg.
Yes.
Representative Tucker.
Representative Go Marlow.
Yes.
Representative Loughman.
Representative Gorg.
Yes.
Representative Loughman.
Representative Gorg.
Yes.
I see you on video.
Thank you.
Representative Hacken Phillips.
Yes.
Representative Murphy.
Representative Major.
Yes.
And then Representative Urali needs to be on video.
Thank you.
Murphy?
Yes.
Representative Major?
And then Representative Urali needs to be on video.
Representative Ulrich, could you enable your video and cast your vote?
I don't have video.
he can't take he can't take place okay i'm going to record uh him as not voting on this therefore the vote is 22 to nothing the vote being 22 to nothing the motion of what to pass on house bill 281 fn passes consent mr chairman okay the next bill mr chair i think it was representative elliott who requested that this be put on the consent calendar.
Can you speak a little louder?
Representative Bernstein?
There was a request to put this bill on the consent calendar.
Yes.
So I think at this point, maybe ask everyone if there's any objection to that.
Okay.
Anybody have any objection going on the consent calendar for 281?
Representative Alvin?
I actually I don't know how my hand went up.
Every time I move near the computer, it seems to change.
I agree to consent calendar.
I think it's complicated to explain to the general body.
and we're all in favor.
So there's nobody that raised their hand in opposition to the consent calendar.
So we'll go on to consent.
sounds.
The next one is House Bill 353.
And that's one where a lot of work needs to be done on that.
And do I hear a motion to retain that?
On House Bill 353?
I would move to retain.
Sorry, I didn't realize- I'll second it, I had my hand up.
Okay, who made the motion to retain?
I did.
Representative Ames.
And seconded.
Bye.
Second.
I'll second.
2-5-3.
Representative Abramny, Representative Ames, you want to speak to the motion?
I think that the question that's raised by this bill is interesting and potentially there is a significant issue related to whether or not there should be credit for taxes paid to another state on an interest in dividends return.
But there are questions that couldn't be answered in the short time that we've had and that we will have given restrictions of the pandemic that we're experiencing.
And thus, it seems a very good candidate for more careful consideration through the retained bill process.
And that's why I have moved for retention.
Anybody elsements on retaining?
Representative Major, if I had my hand.
Representative Eleanor.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
If you'll recall, the DRA testified that they do not think that this is constitutional.
There are two different versions of attacks in consideration, one from Massachusetts, another from New Hampshire.
And generally, the U.S.
Supreme Court has ruled that this is not double taxation and that they would be fighting this in court if it came through that way.
And then there was also a question of what it would cost.
And they said that they could work on a fiscal note, but they didn't really think that they were going to be doing a good job of it.
And we thought perhaps they might do a good job of it if they had the summer to work on it.
Any further comments or questions?
Seeing none, then I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on.
Retaining House Bill 353.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
In the interest of time, I will exclude the word representative so we can just go down this list.
Let's start the vote with Abrami.
But yes.
Melvin.
Yes.
All agreed.
He can't vote.
He doesn't have his video.
Got it.
Ober.
Yes.
Clark votes yes.
Doucette.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Doucette?
Yes.
Elliot?
Junijian?
Yes.
Nunez?
Baxter?
Yes.
Spillsbury?
Tudor?
Yes.
Almi?
Bill Burry.
Yes.
Tudor.
Almi.
Yes.
Spillsbury.
Tudor.
Yes.
Almy.
Ames.
Yes.
Southworth.
Malloy.
Yes.
Schaumburg.
Tucker.
Yes.
Marlow.
Lothman.
Gorg.
Yes.
Hacken Phillips.
Loughman.
Gorg.
Yes.
Hacken Phillips.
Murphy.
Yes.
Major.
22 to love.
It passed.
22 to zero?
Correct.
Any objections?
There's no consent calendar for that.
We just recorded out as being retained.
So the vote to retain 22 to nothing passes.
Mr.
Speaker, may I ask Representative Burstein, on 281, did you get, you did not get a vote from Griffin.
Is that correct?
Representative Charles Melvin was substituting for Griffin and he voted yes.
Thank you.
And what was Representative Melvin's vote on 353?
Yes.
The vote, his vote was yes.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
The next bill to vote on is House Bill 533, establishing Division of Investigation and Compliance in the Lottery Commission.
Do I have a motion?
Representative Bromney.
Yes, I make a motion.
I'll pass on House Bill 533.
Seconded by.
Second.
Representative Schamburg.
Bromney makes a motion.
I'll pass.
Representative Schamburg seconded it.
Representative Bromney.
Thank you.
I think we've had...
Next motion I'll to pass.
Representative Schamberg seconds it.
Representative Romney.
Thank you.
I think we've had a long discussion on this already.
It creates, it basically codifies what he already has in terms of investigation and compliance people.
He wants to formalize it and make it a division within the lottery.
There are no new staff involved here.
Understand this is the only early bill we have.
It will be going to finance.
I'll be up here to testify.
But I think they're quickly going to realize there's no FTEs or no new positions.
and then the other thing it does is it changes the relationship, not change the relationship.
Basically what it does is it picks up more of the duties when it comes to doing facts and meeting information gathering, when it comes to looking at the license that you want to watch our gaming place or those kind of things.
Thank you.
looking at license to those kind of things we really can't hear yes I think it's when perhaps if we're going to have such a long explanation we have to straighten it out or just forego that because we cannot understand what's being said.
All right.
I'll try it again.
So the last thing it does is it, it, it changes the way that the lottery commission works with the AG's office.
Lottery commission will pick up a lot of the background gathering on people applying for licenses and but remember that the AG's office continues to have make that final call if someone is worthy of or fit to receive a gambling license of any kind and that is my testimony that is my comments and we heard you perfectly clearly then.
Just for you, Edith.
I don't see any.
Thank you.
Mr.
Chair, you're muted.
I think I heard you through somebody else's mic saying you're muted.
Normal, you're muted on your mic.
Is you're muted?
Sorry about that.
I didn't see any other raised hands.
Anybody else want to make comments or questions?
Send none, then I'll ask the clerk to call the roll.
House Bill 533, the motion is ought to pass.
Let's begin with Abrami.
Yeah.
Melvin.
All are recorded as a no vote as not voting over.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Do set.
Yes.
Elliot.
You need Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Doucette.
Yes.
Elliot.
Janijian.
Yes.
Nunez.
Baxter.
Yes.
Spillsbury.
Tudor.
Yes.
Almy.
Ames.
Yes.
Southworth.
Malloy.
Yes.
Southworth.
Malloy.
Yes.
Chamburg.
Tucker.
Yes.
Thank you.
Gamarlo?
Yes.
Loffman?
No, not voting.
Loffman.
Gorg.
Yes.
Hacken Phillips.
Murphy.
Yes.
Major.
Mr.
Chair, there are 22 yay votes and two members not voting.
All right, the vote been 22-0.
The motion passes on House Bill 533.
Anybody object to putting it on consent?
Anybody object to putting 533 on the consent calendar?
I don't see it, so go on consent.
Mr.
Speaker, may I ask Representative Burstein on 353, that vote was to retain, just to confirm?
353.
Correct.
Thank you.
Okay.
That's all.
You're exactly.
Now the rest of them will consider next week when we have our work session on the bills that we hear today and the remainder of the bills we heard on the 28th.
So you can come back at 1 o'clock.
So I would recommend just muting your video and muting your audio.
I wanted to suggest that when you're moving around, there seems to be more back and forth, more echoes.
Thank you.
I don't need a nap.
You need a nap.
You really do.
Representative Elliot, it looks like your video and your audio are still going.
I wanted to make you aware so that you could mute and stop your feed.
Okay, how do I get out?
You can just turn, if you run your cursor on the bottom of the screen, you can stop your video.
Oh, stop the video?
Okay.
And then just to the left of that should be stop audio or mute.
Put it on mute.
There you go.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, just set.
Thank you.
Vielen Dank.
Yes.
Test, test.
Test.
Test, test, test.
Hello?
Do you have a device on over there?
I don't have any of that.
Okay.
Hello?
I think it's this thing.
The thing right here, the power?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Yeah, that was the issue.
This whole time.
Do you think that's it?
Well, that was the issue with the feedback.
The other issue we had this morning was the computer that was hooked up to this completely failed.
It's nuts.
It's audio card just stopped working.
So it had no ability to have any microphone input or output.
Test, test, test.
OK.
No feedback.
That's for sure.
Test, Test.
We'll solve it, Aaron.
I don't know if it's solved yet.
What's the system?
What's it do?
Brand new.
This picture, let me find it here.
Thank you.
I actually hired this guy for YouTube.
return Thank you.
Thank you.
This is an audio test.
Microphone is in the room.
Test one, two.
This is just for testing purposes.
How's the clarity of the audio?
Very good.
Okay, thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
Very good.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
I'm doing a test by text message and I got live feedback.
Okay.
So I think your room is back online.
Thank you.
So, Representative Abrami.
Norm's trying it on the regular, you know, the normal system.
So they did a sound check during lunch and it was much, much clearer.
All right.
So let's try this, Norm.
Should.
Let me make sure it's not muted over here.
She said they did a sound check.
Okay.
One,.
Testing one, two, three.
Does that work?
Yeah, that's great.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
I happen to be where my computer is at lunch, and I heard them do the sound check and was able to tell them how clear it was.
Very nice guy.
Okay.
Well, these speakers aren't working on that speaker.
Yeah.
I'm getting their voice through on my computer.
Oops, there we go again.
That's cause of me.
Yeah, make sure you turn down your speakers to Representative Abrami.
Yeah, I'm gonna turn this off if we get this.
But the sound, the voices aren't coming through the speakers by the screen, the big screen.
You don't need to do that.
My sense earlier was it made an enormous amount of difference when you leaned in towards your speaker.
It changed everything.
Okay, we have but we don't none of the sound is coming out of the speaker in the room so i was just going to sound totally off of zoom uh but until we so when people speak we still can't hear it through the speaker that's in front of the screen here the big screen right now you sound good representative abrami i don't hear an echo when you were speaking just now so you can't hear us is that the problem no i can hear you on my computer i was gonna i was gonna sign off zoom but we're not hearing your voices through the speakers that are in the room but you don't maybe you don't need to.
They had to just set right.
I wouldn't go turning other stuff on.
Unless you absolutely...
I'm going to turn my sound down here.
Okay.
Let's see if you can hear anybody.
My speaker's down to zero.
All right.
Okay, testing.
One, two, three.
How's that?
Perfect.
Good.
Are you hearing it through your computer?
You heard the response.
I heard the response.
The response was like.
Through your computer, though.
Yeah, I've got to somehow turn up my sound on the receiver.
So if I turn my computer off totally, I won't be able to hear.
So Representative Ames, were you aware that your computer was on?
We all heard all your messages from your telephone?
I couldn't quite hear you.
No, I didn't hear that.
I didn't know that.
There's something to be aware of.
The Valley News recalled you.
Oh, really?
So you've already heard about it last night.
No, I haven't.
I haven't spoken to anyone.
These are just messages.
I'm sorry that they were public.
Yeah, I can hear through that speaker.
I heard somebody had called me.
Some of us had our volume down, so we couldn't.
I couldn't get to my computerized telephone book when I'm in Zoom.
Oh, it's after one o'clock.
I only have one computer.
I don't have a laptop.
Actually Norm's voice is quite strong now.
181, yeah.
representative aims I had my stuff muted but when I turned it on and I heard you I muted you so some of them went up thank you thank you Janine I can hardly hear you are you talking to me representative major yes can everybody else hear me okay yes oh boy I don't know what to say.
Jennifer?
Do the best we can.
I'll try and speak up when I need to.
Is that better?
Yes.
Okay.
Hi, y'all.
Woo.
Yes.
Okay, might as well get started on the next hearing.
I'm going to open a public hearing on House Bill 181, an act relative to the local options for operation of sports book retail locations.
And I'm not sure who to let in because nobody signed up.
Michael O'Brien is this, I want to know, Michael O'Brien is this prime.
Yeah, and I don't see that name on the attendees.
Cody.
Representative Cody is on the attendee list but he's not testifying.
It's not on mine.
let's ask him if there's anybody out there.
Yeah.
Is there anybody there?
Raise your hand if you if you're going to introduce the bill.
Introduce the bill.
Is there anybody that's going to be introducing House Bill 181?
It's sponsors are Representative O'Brien from Hillsborough, Representative Tolesky from Hillsborough, Representative Cody from Hillsborough, and Senator Rosenwald from District 13.
I got one.
Tolesky will testify.
Talking permitted.
Good afternoon.
Yes, we hear you.
Thank you.
I apologize.
I didn't receive any notice that Representative O'Brien wouldn't be here.
I just happened to join to follow the proceeding.
So I suppose I will present the bill on his behalf.
I apologize if I don't have any necessary information or I'm able to answer any questions you might have.
House Bill 181 came about as a result of the question on sports betting failing on one of our Nashua ballots by a very, very slim margin.
When we looked at the possibility of resubmitting the question, we saw that the existing statute limited us as to which ballots we could put it on.
This bill was submitted last year with the hopes of getting it on the state primary ballot.
At this point, since the state primary has passed, I'm not exactly sure as to what the intention was with Representative O'Brien filing it again, but I do believe they were looking for flexibility in terms of being able to put the question on a ballot at a different election instead of just the municipal election.
And that's what I understand of the issue.
Well, thank you, Representative.
Would you take any questions?
I can try.
Do we have any questions?
Yeah, I do.
Robson Ames, do you have a question?
I do.
I'm sorry.
I was trying to find the raise my hand icon.
But yeah, I wonder if you can tell us what the relative turnout in numbers is between a primary election and the other actions that are available.
I'm sorry I interrupted you.
I don't actually know specific details of the numbers for a municipal turnout versus a state primary.
I do know that there was concerns about the limitation on the number of licenses that would be going out.
And Nashville wanted to try one more time to get it on the ballot to our voters.
We feel that there just wasn't enough time to educate the voters about the issues and felt like if we had a chance to explain the benefits that our local nonprofits could receive from the program, that we would have a better turnout on the question.
In terms of your, I'm sorry, I don't know the answer specifically to the number of voters.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Romney.
So thank you for your testimony.
Do we know how many, I guess, cities have biannual elections?
Does Nashville have biannual elections?
Thank you for the question.
Yes, our municipality has on off years of the state elections, we have our municipal elections.
So the only option is to do it in the September primary election.
Is that what I'm hearing on the off year?
That was what the plan was to do.
But, and this was a bill was put in one of the omnibus bills last June.
I don't know specifically which one it was put into, but it was a bunch of of administrative kind of changes.
And it was vetoed by the governor.
So that situation of getting it onto the September primary that happened just this past year, we lost that opportunity.
And like I said, the fact that Representative O'Brien, I'm not sure what his plan was, if him not being here was a change in the intention of the bill, I have no idea.
And I apologize about that.
Representative Major, may I interrupt?
Go ahead.
I guess the question for ways and means would be, should we allow town to have a second chance?
And I think we do this with other things like Keno and other kind of lottery kind of things that we allow a town to continue to vote to be able to bring this up on ballot.
So, and I guess the only reason that I see this bill here is I haven't had a chance to look at the original language of the sports book.
I'm surprised if it didn't have language that said it could be brought up again and again.
Is that your understanding that it doesn't have that kind of language or is it just this biannual issue that affects Nashua that we're we're talking about here?
I'm pretty sure it was the biannual issue that affects Nashua that we're talking about here?
I'm pretty sure it was the biannual issue that the fear that the, I believe it's 10, and you can correct me if I'm wrong, it's 10 licenses that are available, that they would be all distributed before we had the chance to ask the question again two years later.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah, two licenses have been issued so far.
So, okay, so, but is your, when's your next election?
Is it this, is it this?
November 20, it's November 2021.
November 2021.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Major, this is Jenny.
There are three people here from Lottery, just so you know.
Okay.
There is Representative Tom Southworth.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I think you've partly answered the question.
For Nashua's issue, again, you're going to do the vote again in November.
So in some respect, your issue is solved for now.
Thank you for the question.
That was one that I was trying to figure out.
I know that we were all co-sponsors on this bill last year um and as far as and i apologize again that i don't know if there were other conversations that happened um between the prime sponsor and everyone else but um that was the plan that uh we would move forward with the bill but yes according to the the fact that that municipal elections can have the question right now, I believe that would be work out for Nash when we would have it in November.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Representative Alamey.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
So I'm guessing your biennial municipal election is this year?
Yes.
Okay.
And the other part was about the September state primary election was added because you hoped the bill would be passed last year.
Correct.
Can we take it out?
It seems to be only Nashua that's affected by this.
That I don't know.
Any other questions or comments?
Mr.
Chairman, if I may?
Yes.
I will make some phone calls and make sure that nothing has changed with the prime sponsor.
And I would like to be able to give you an update on the status.
And again, I apologize if the intention of the prime sponsor was to not have the bill presented.
but felt a responsibility since I was viewing the the hearing to step up and at least give you the facts behind the bill if that would be okay I can do that that's fine we'll continue this bill the next time we meet and i think that's the 10th right?
Yeah let's hear a lot.
But we'll hear from lottery.
Thank you.
Who is it from lottery?
It's Charlie.
Charlie and there's Danny Maloney and there's John Conforti and I've allowed them all to talk so they can decide who.
Charlie McIntyre Good afternoon, Mr.
Chair, members of the committee.
This is Charlie McIntyre speaking for the lottery at first and happy to answer your questions you have related to this bill.
Obviously this wasn't our submission.
This was membership from Nashua that wanted this bill filed.
Thank you.
submission.
This was membership from Nashua that wanted this bill filed.
Charlie, can you repeat that?
Certainly.
Yeah.
No, that's true.
Obviously, Nashua being a gateway city to New Hampshire, I think they were looking to have another chance to vote last fall in their election.
I do believe they plan on putting it on a ballot this fall.
And certainly for us, Nashville represents an important location for a facility, for a sports book.
And with the speed Massachusetts seems to be moving at, we would like to do this obviously as fast as possible because we do have an interest in having a location in Nashville.
All right.
Any questions of Charlie?
Susan?
I mean, Representative Almey.
Thank you.
and Charlie is there.!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Thank you for the question.
I don't know the answer to that.
I only know about Nashua.
Do I have a question?
Representative Bromney.
Charlie, Representative Bromney.
So the statutes are pretty clear that they can revote.
It sounds like Nashua has an interesting situation here that's different, but it looks like this coming year, if we pass this, it would be a vote in September instead of November.
They're able to vote in November on this.
So it doesn't appear that there's an issue for now.
I guess we're going to hear back from the representative who introduced the bill as to whether we need to modify this or even have this bill.
Is that your understanding?
Is that what your take on this is as well?
I mean, I can, Representative Armby, I can certainly suggest to you that a two-month difference for us would be helpful versus September versus November only because we will be competing for Massachusetts customers there and two months of lead time will help if that's the difference in the bill.
Okay thank you so it would make a difference okay thank you.
Any further questions or comments?
Yes.
Representative Alame.
Thank you.
Maybe I'm reading the bill wrong.
As I understand it, it allows you to do this at the next annual town meeting or regular municipal election.
That's going to be in November at this point.
And, but a city with biannual elections, which is Nashua, may conduct the vote on at the September state primary election.
There is no September state primary election this year.
Of course.
Okay, then obviously we will wait for November if that is the case.
And if that is the case, isn't it true that the law also already allows it?
Representative Abrami probably knows.
Do you have an answer for that, Charlie?
Yeah, certainly.
I mean, the benefit obviously would be if it doesn't pass this fall, that it would be available to be voted upon next fall without having to refile a bill again.
No, but without the...
Okay.
Are you all set, Representative Alony?
Yes, I...
Representative Southwood.
Thank you.
Can you hear me all right?
Yes.
My question would be, elections do have different kinds of turnouts, and I would be concerned municipal elections really have a different focus than primaries, and to me, something like this really is localized, and at least initially, I would think it would belong in the municipal category.
Thank you.
Any other questions or comments?
Here we go, one more.
I'm simply unfamiliar with this question.
I've never seen a substantive question put at a primary.
Is there precedent for this?
Should I restate?
I couldn't hear you.
Okay.
My question is simply out of unfamiliarity.
I've never seen a substantive question of this sort put on a primary election ballot.
Is there any precedent for it?
Who wants to answer that?
I think we need to ask election law.
Yeah, makes sense.
Actually, surprise isn't It wasn't an early bill.
Yeah.
All right.
I don't see.
Yeah.
All right.
I don't see anybody signed up.
So and nobody else would testify.
So I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 181.
Okay.
We've got another six minutes to wait to hear the public hearing on hospital.
3.30.
shall I keep the three lottery gentlemen in here or put them back to attendees or not talking uh we can't hear you i just asked if i should leave lottery on because the next two have to do with lottery yes okay thank you lottery.
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Ways and Means Committee.
He's going to go where we can.
We should have asked on municipal expert about this last one.
Yeah.
That seemed kind of odd though, right?
There's something on a primary ballot like this.
Yeah.
Mr.
Chair.
We'll have a discussion I guess my mic is live huh I have no way of turning it off, so.
Yeah.
Are you part of norms, Mike?
Because I don't even see your name up here anymore, Representative Abrami.
Oh, I turned my computer off.
Oh, okay.
I'm just looking at you guys on the big screen and using the mic that's connected to the computer.
Okay.
Computer here.
Yeah.
The main soundboard, I guess.
And Representative Lang is in the room when you're ready.
Well, his room, but our room.
Good afternoon, everybody.
No, no, no.
Not ready yet.
You just hanged it afternoon.
Yeah.
We have to wait till 1.30.
Thank you.
Well, we're waiting just to remind the committee that we will have a work session on all the bills that we've heard thus far.
And that's gonna be on the 10th of next week, which would be Wednesday.
So if you have any amendments, bring them in that day.
The bills.
We're going to have work session on revenues on Tuesday, and then work session on the bills on Wednesday.
Mr.
Chair, tip-off for both of those days is 9 o'clock AM.
Is that correct?
Yes.
So it's Wednesday the 10th and then the next Wednesday?
I think he said Tuesday the 9th and Wednesday the 10th and then the next Wednesday?
I think he said Tuesday the 9th and Wednesday the 10th.
No, he said two Wednesdays.
New bills.
So the 10th is just what's up.
And hopefully we'll be able to get some more bills out.
Exactly.
All right, we're ready.
Then I'll open the public hearing on House Bill 330, an act relative to sports locations.
The prime sponsor here is Representative Lang.
Representative Lang, you want to introduce your bill.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, members of the House Ways and Means Committee.
I present House Bill 330 to you, a nice one-page simple bill, which you're probably not used to seeing.
This bill does two basic things.
The first thing it does is it allows what's called tier two betting, um, tier two at retail locations.
Um, in my original bill that I sponsored back in 2019, uh, for sports betting, tier two betting was allowed in the retail locations.
And then it passed the house, including retail locations.
But when it made it over to the Senate, the Senate took out tier two betting at retail locations.
And the reason I included this back in is, A, it's just illogical not to include it.
If you understand what tier two betting is, tier two betting is what's called in-game betting.
And so say this Sunday, the Super Bowl kicks off.
And after the kickoff, I decide I want to place a wager on who's going to score the most points in the second half of the Super Bowl.
I would could open up my app and I could place that bet.
however if I was at a sports book retail location like the brook out in um uh the Seabrook or the one in Manchester, and the name's escaping me right now, I could not go up to the cage and place that bet.
I would have to take out my phone and I could place that bet while I'm in that location, but I literally cannot go in and place a bet for an in-game bet while I'm at the retail sports locations.
It just seemed a little illogical to me, the fact that I can't do it when I'm sitting in there and help with the ancillary revenue for that business, but I could whip out my phone and I could do it on my phone.
It just seems illogical to me.
And I think it will help both the businesses as well as the revenue projection, increased revenues for allowing that tier two betting.
The second thing this bill does is, again, which wasn't in my original bill, the original bill was modified to put a limit on the number of locations throughout the state that sports betting could be offered.
And they put a 10 retail location cap on.
This bill just removes that cap, that artificial cap.
My conversations with Charlie McIntyre, I honestly don't know that we'll ever get over 10.
I just don't like the idea that we artificially limit what retail operations can happen within a state by it within a statute.
So as the state grows and as this opportunities grow, I want the statute to be future proof and allow for that growth to happen.
Charlie has done a phenomenal job over at Lottery, and I am sure that he will manage the locations as necessary.
Again, the number of locations was kind of a dark throw that they made.
I don't know that there's any logic behind what number there's there.
They've been picking 10.
It was just the number that for some reason, I think it was the House put on last in 19 and added it to the bill.
I'd like to see it removed and let the free market manage this process.
If the business owner wants to open a business, it's his, his return on investment.
He has to decide whether it's profitable for him or not and let that happen.
And the last thing I'll say is that sports book has done, been done great for the state of New Hampshire.
I'm sure Charlie might give the most current numbers, but we've seen some, you know, over $10 million given to education through this one simple new law we put in in 2019.
And so I'd like to see that continue.
I'd like to see our charity, the casino charity gaming operations be able to thrive.
And I believe that this simple change in these two, in this one set of statutes will do that.
I'm happy to take questions, but also understand Charlie's here.
And if you have questions about how Lottery's doing on the revenues, he'd be the guy to ask.
Thank you for taking my hand, Professor Lang.
On line four, can you remind us what Tier 3, it looks like we had Tier 1 and then they added Tier 2.
So in line four it goes and Tier 3 sports wagers.
What are tier three sports wagers?
So tier three, per the statute, the definition in the RSA is tier three sports wager.
It means a sports wager that is neither tier one or tier two.
So if it doesn't fit in the pregame bet and it doesn't fit in the current game bet, my understanding, then it's a tier three bet.
And my understanding, this was an opening that allowed lottery to create lottery products that they could offer that would be classified as sports wager.
And again, Charlie might be the better person to ask.
But that was my understanding was tier three is a lottery product as compared to a DraftKings product.
Follow up.
There's a link.
So you're saying that this was renumbered then?
It was tier one, then tier two was added.
Was tier three, was that tier two before?
Nope.
So the original language of the bill just had tier one and three, they took out tier two.
And so I, so I added tier two back in allow again for that situation where if I'm sitting watching a Superbowl, I could go place a bet on what's going to happen in the second half of the game during the first half of the game.
Okay.
So it was approved with the tier three in it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Before we go to Charlie, we have one other person who wants to speak and support, and that's Craig Moore.
Susan, I mean, Representative Elmy, you have a question?
Yes, I did.
I learned after we passed the sports betting stuff that from Willis Griffith, who is no longer on this committee, I saw you last week, and I learned that he was really worried that the younger people, which he represents, would use the tier two type of bedding to compulsively be bedding all the time when they were supposed to be working or looking for a job or something.
And it seems to me ironic that we have it for the phones, but we do not have it for the physical associations.
And I was wondering if I've got that right to Representative Lang, who knows much more about these things than I do.
So thank you for the question, Representative Alvami, and it was very seeing you again as well.
So I'm sure Charlie can talk about that.
We built into the law problem gaming aspect of this and reporting on problem gaming.
And to my knowledge, we haven't had any problems with tier two betting on the phone.
That has been problematic.
And that there's even a self-blocking feature within the applications that would block.
You can stop that tier two bet.
So to my knowledge, there's been no issue with this compulsive behavior.
It hasn't manifested itself.
But even before we even waited for it to manifest itself, we did put in some criteria in the law about reporting and self-reporting and analytics regarding this kind of activity so that it can be captured by the businesses we have this private partner relationship with.
and I know that DraftKings has a relationship and I can't remember the name of the business they work with that developed the analytics to watch for compulsive gaming behaviors.
But I do know they have that built into the application and built into the system to protect against that.
All right.
No more questions.
So, Greg Moore representing Americans for Prosperity in New Hampshire.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
My name is Greg Moore.
I'm the state director with Americans for Prosperity here in New Hampshire.
And we're supportive of House Bill 330, largely because of the secondary provision of removing the cap on the number of physical locations.
And while, as the sponsor said, we may never get to the point where we come even close to having 10 of these facilities across the state.
We think it's critical to have a good competitive marketplace in order to have high quality, high value facilities for the consumers across the state.
And we also just feel as though, as soon as you put an artificial cap on an entity, you end up with a dynamic much like the proverbial New York City taxi medallions, which ultimately can create a situation where the actual license itself becomes a thing of value versus putting the focus instead on the quality product for the consumers.
This is, I think, a very positive step making this change.
It will ensure that the lottery doesn't have to pick and choose among potential good locations across the state right now, considering that the actual location is one of the criteria in the statute for the siting of these, given the limited number.
It's likely that, for example, a city like Manchester would never see another potential facility in the city.
Well, that means that ultimately the quality for that facility obviously doesn't need to be particularly high if it's literally the only show in town.
and having the ability to have a competitor come into the nearby market and be able to join, which results in a better value for the consumer, we view that as a positive.
Also, as we heard in the last bill that came before this committee, times and opinions change.
So if a town didn't provide a local option at the first onset, and then all 10 licenses are given up up but then they decided that they would like to try to have a sports gaming facility in their community well then too bad the the train has left the station and you either would need to wait for one of these facilities to fold which again because it's because of the nature of the law it's unlikely any of these facilities would ever fold they'd probably sell and they would be able to sell at a premium, again, much like a taxi medallion, because the actual contract has a value in and of itself.
So for all those reasons, we think it's important to encourage strong competition and ultimately provide more consumer choice, which I think benefits everybody, including state revenues over the long term.
So thank you for the time to speak here today and I welcome any questions.
Any questions for Mr.
Moore?
Representative Schoenberg.
Mr.
Moore, are you suggesting then that just a free market or a limit?
I couldn't quite hear you.
We can't hear from here.
I apologize.
Yes, we believe that having no limitations on an actual cap is the appropriate strategy.
So we're supportive of the second part of Representative Lange's bill.
I mean, the first part makes sense, too, to me.
But our real focus is on the second part of the Lang's bill.
I mean, the first part makes sense too, to me, but our real focus is on the second part of the legislation, the aspect that eliminates the cap of 10 total licensees.
Thank you.
Further questions on Mr.
Moore?
I don't see any, so Charlie McIntyre is here.
Charlie.
Good afternoon again Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
Charlie McIntyre here.
Certainly this bill in terms of opening up tier two to the retail facilities makes sense to us.
There are a number of wagers that can be placed as Representative Lang correctly points out regarding like, you know, who wins the third quarter, how many total points are scored, bets that can happen in game at the retail locations, which makes sense to us.
As you know, obviously we only have two locations.
So 10 would be a lot for us, but certainly no opposition to removing the cap and allowing the businesses that we talk to decide whether it's in their best interest to open up a retail sports book with our regulations or not.
And happy to answer any questions you or the members of the committee may have.
Representative Romlee.
Hi, Charlie.
How are you doing?
I have a question for each piece of this bill.
So I've spoken to the folks at Seabrook and at Manchester who have sportsbook, and they're very, well, they have people from out of state, especially at Seabrook that are there, they're in the chairs and they feel that they really should be allowed to have, and then when these folks go to do the tier two vetting, they have to go to their phones and they feel that they are being short-term.
These people are in their building and they don't get any credit, if you will, for that bet.
And so have you heard the same concerns from those two locations?
Yeah, President Bobby, thank you for the question.
We have, we have had the number of reports that folks are playing on the phone while seated at a facility and it's causing them lost revenues in terms of obviously not just the wager but also not consuming food and beverages.
So yes, we've heard those.
Follow up.
So in terms of the increasing the number from 10, I don't know if at this point I'm not convinced that's a good idea, but it seems to me that it would really kind of thin out the risk that these folks are taking.
You may want to explain how this works and that the actual facilities, there isn't like absolutely no risk for them when these bets occur.
Can you explain that risk that they take, Charlie?
Certainly.
Based on our existing structure, a facility shares in the risk along with the state.
It receives a percentage of the win for the month, but also is credited or debited a loss for the month.
Like, for example, there are months the state at a physical retail book will lose money if one popular team wins versus an unpopular team.
And so there are swings monthly back and forth.
Now, over the course of the year, it's positive.
We make money at this, but it's a risk factor.
And based on our regulations, as well as the regulations of DraftKings, it is an expensive proposition to open up a retail sports book it's many many hundreds of thousands of dollars just in labor costs to run a physical sports book because of all the necessary regulations we have at these facilities because there is indeed a lot of money going through them both through both facilities now so they share risk with us there's not a guaranteed return for them.
If that's your question.
Thank you.
Okay.
Representative Almey.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I was wondering if Charlie has any idea why, are there others not applying or they're not capable of handling it?
Why are there only two at this point?
Well, obviously, we want to start slow.
So these are the first two we identified as being disparate regionally.
And COVID got in the way, candidly, because of the social distancing and that adding to expenses and adding to or detracting from additional revenue options.
You can't have folks seated close together on all those things.
And so we've had a number of meetings with people.
We've also, DraftKings has been contacted by folks, and we will be opening up further locations.
It was just hard to do it in the middle of a pandemic.
Representative Ames.
Yeah, thank you.
So on this proposal, I'm fine with the tier two edition, by the way.
But my question relates to the sports books and the change, moving the cap of 10 in terms of numbers of locations in the state.
Now last year I chaired the subcommittee in this committee that worked on this bill and we worked through quite a number of changes to get to a point where they could get strong support out of our committee.
And one of those changes was this one to put in that cap.
I don't have a clear memory of the discussion, but it was seen as, I think, a limit on something that we didn't really know here in New Hampshire and we didn't know how it would develop.
And there's, as everybody knows, nervousness about having widespread gambling locations in New Hampshire that's held, that sort of dictates how many people respond to gambling here in New Hampshire.
So we thought setting a cap on the number of locations would be helpful in showing a sort of prudent approach to this new form of gambling.
And so that limitation of 10 was put into the bill.
And when I represented what the bill did on the floor and in the blurb for the committee, I mentioned it.
And here we are now with only two locations in the state.
And we've got a cap of 10.
And COVID undoubtedly got in the way of working for more than two.
But I guess what I'm trying to say is that it's too early.
It seems to me too early.
Maybe you can respond to this, Charlie, as to why it wouldn't be more, it wouldn't be sort of equally possible in terms of dealing with this limit to deal with it later after we had more experience under our belts, had a better understanding of what a sports book is, what it looks like and how it impacts statewide, whether sort of a lack of any limit is a good thing to go to or not.
So that's my question to you, Charlie.
Certainly.
Representative Ames, thank you for the question.
Under the current construct, I don't see us hitting above the 10 now.
What would likely to be the case would be is if technology and a revision of our agreement with DraftKings allowed is to have smaller sports book locations, if that makes sense.
Sort of a, you know, you have like a, like a bank has a branch, like we would have branch offices versus the headquarters.
The, there's a limit on the number now because they're so expensive to run.
But if we were, if draft Kings was, was to reframe how we do it, to have smaller sort of like ATMs have banks, you know, if we had those, like so in sports bars, for example, then we would do that and that would run afoul of the 10.
If that makes sense to your question, Representative Ames.
Well, thank you.
Representative Southworth.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Charlie, for taking my question.
Could you say a little more about the safety mechanisms you have for problem gambling, and a little more about how you really know if there is any problem gambling in this type of betting?
Well, certainly.
Obviously, it wasn't important to us.
It's one of the factors which actually was considered in the RFP process originally and scored as well.
And DraftKings has a robust facility for this.
And we have betting limits, obviously, on the app as well, and deposits, obviously.
And we also we also have um we check our director sports betting checks the amount of activity each person has um one of the odd things about sports wagering is that it's a large volume business but it's not a high margin business which means you can bet a lot of money over time and not lose much for example you can you can bet, you know, $500 a week, which seems like a lot would be $25,000 over the course of a year.
But since you're only losing 7% on average, you're losing about, you know, what is that?
$1,700 over the course of a year, which is, you know, breaking down to, you know, $35 a week.
So, we do have it.
We have a process in place.
And I don't know if Danny wants to speak to it or John, additionally, if you guys are on, you can, please.
Sure.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
This is John Conforti.
I'm the chief compliance officer for the New Hampshire Lottery.
And just to build out on what Charlie said, we have responsible gaming programs both on the mobile app, on the phone, and also in the physical retail locations.
A large portion of that is the limits, as Charlie indicated.
There are self-exclusions.
There are reference pages for help, both nationally and locally, that can get problem gamblers connected with services.
so that is really baked into the product on the mobile side and also on the retail side as charlie said both for responsible gaming and for risk management purposes we keep it very really baked into the product on the mobile side and also on the retail side.
As Charlie said, both for responsible gaming and for risk management purposes, we keep a very close eye on the wagering activities that take place, the high volume wagering or high dollar number wagering.
And we're very watchful of that activity along with DraftKings.
And we identify specifically any I'll see you next time.
And we identify specifically any concerning behavior and address that as we go.
So there are programs that are operational.
People have taken advantage both of the limits that are available and the self-exclusion program and that's something that we continuously monitor in fact we just did our first year review and did a review and an update on responsible gambling based on what we learned in the first year so that is something that we're continuously monitoring and improving on.
Thank you.
Could I do a follow-up?
Absolutely.
My question really is, I'm glad you're watchful and that we built those safeguards in.
I remember it very well.
What I'm not quite hearing though, you're watching and so on.
Have you seen a lot of cases, a few cases?
I really, I want a more, you know, image of that.
We haven't seen any activity that we have found to be particularly concerning.
We obviously know that with any gaming activity, there's going to be a percentage of people who have struggles with that.
And what we have seen representative Southworth is that people have taken advantages of self-limiting and self-exclusion policies.
So those have been adopted.
So people have identified that they've needed help.
They have reached out to the resources here in New Hampshire.
We've seen some people who have come through that come to the Council for Responsible Gambling through those links, but we haven't seen a particular surge in problem gambling or problematic behavior.
What we've seen is people utilizing the the tools that we've put in place, we've certainly seen that.
Thank you.
That's helpful.
Representative Tucker.
Yes, this is a director, Mr.
McIntyre.
So I'm sort of intrigued with your concept of branches to larger facilities.
If that's the case that you think that things...
Representative Tucker?
Yes?
Can you speak up louder?
Oh, yes, I'm sorry.
I'm interested in the concept of the branches that you spoke of that might make it so that the number 10 should no longer be the cap.
But I wonder why you wouldn't wait until things slim down and trim down that you could have that kind of configuration and possibly less regulation that you believe is quite onerous now and expensive.
Why wouldn't you wait until those things took place to take an interest in coming over, having a cap removed of 10?
It seems that two is so far from 10.
I just can't see coming up with no cap when those things haven't happened yet.
Certainly.
Thank you for the question.
I was more explaining how we could run the file of the 10 under the current framework versus saying it's a good idea and then that would be our next business model.
that was more my suggestion is there are a number of facilities that would like to engage in this type of activity that cannot now because of the economics of it and that if the economics changed we would like to engage in this type of activity that cannot now because of the economics of it.
And that if the economics changed, we would like to expand into that and wouldn't wanna wait for that to happen, the cap to be lifted, that's all.
Could I follow up please?
Follow up?
Yes.
Why is that that you wouldn't wanna wait?
I I would think that you'd want to focus in on what the changes were in the industry to make sure that New Hampshire was going in the right direction at that time.
So, Representative Tucker, thank you.
I certainly view my charge as to responsibly raise as much revenue as the state as I can.
So, I can.
So I try and do that every step of the way and like to take advantage of innovation and technology changes almost as they occur versus sort of waiting.
I firmly believe that you folks, this big revenue committee really asked me to drive revenue growth for me and my staff.
And certainly that's what I do.
And so that's why I frame it that way and sort of respond that way.
Thank you.
Representative Elmi.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I would like respectively to compare this with tobacco and liquor.
In excess with liquor and in anything with tobacco, we make considerable amount of revenue off of it.
But at the expense of the health of our population, and in this case, when there isn't good compliance, and I'm really interested in what John Conforti is saying, it's whether there's been any research on these methods.
on you can slip into a lot of people creating enormous problems if they do become problem gamblers.
And so we've got to balance those things.
And we've always tried to balance those things.
I'm especially interested in asking Mr.
Conforti at this point whether it sounds like these systems for finding the problem gamblers and going after them has been developed in a number of places.
and one of the main problems before was that the problem gamblers did not want to acknowledge that and would avoid coming.
It was kind of self-defining.
the main problems before was that the problem gamblers did not want to acknowledge that and would avoid coming.
It was kind of self-defining and they would not come and ask for help.
Has there been research on these yet and to what extent they're effective in getting people to respond to your identification of them thank you representative all me we we have not done uh formal research on that um what we do see is that people are utilizing the tools uh which is very uh good to see um and we have been in contact with the council for Responsible Gambling and very interested in seeing what they are experiencing in terms of the volume of participation or problematic behavior that they've identified.
And thus far, we haven't seen anything that the council itself has believed is problematic.
Obviously, Representative Almi, we're basing that based on what we know and who comes forward.
But again, I would say that there's a great emphasis on this, both from the lottery side, but also from the corporate side, from DraftKings as well.
This is a commitment.
It's both the right thing to do.
It's also in our best interest to make sure that our customers are using the product responsibly.
No one wants to see stories of people spending money that they don't have on an entertainment product.
So I guess as my answer would be, we don't have formal studies of those, but we do know that people are utilizing the tools and that we are going to continue to monitor that usage and make sure that we're working with the Council on Responsible Gambling.
They look at our programs.
They provide us feedback on the best way that we can service problem gamblers and the best way we can reach out to them.
And we're going to continue that dialogue as we go.
This is a continuing process.
Thank you.
Could I clarify the question a bit?
I was asking, I figured you hadn't been doing this for long enough, but I was asking if in other states or other countries there had been study of these particular mechanisms for controlling the problem.
Representative Almey, it's Charlie McIntyre.
If I could, I can probably do you one better in the sense of a significant number of our players come from Massachusetts on the mobile side, and the majority of our players come from Massachusetts on the retail side.
and I can ask the council from Massachusetts, Marlene Warner, who I know quite well, to ask us for data she may have on their players on sports betting, because they'd either be doing it in New Hampshire or Rhode Island, if that makes sense.
That is true.
They are doing research on the bad effects side of things.
So that would be great.
Thank you.
Yes.
Representative Murphy.
Thank you.
Yes.
Representative Murphy.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
My question is not being that familiar with gambling and the question that was brought up about ATMs by Charlie, that concept intrigued me in the sense of the pertinence of the 10 cap.
So my question is, is there a limit to the size of either volume or size of the building that triggers you into that 10?
Or is it you just want to open up a small retail spot anywhere in the state and that qualifies as inclusion to that group of 10?
Currently now, Representative, thank you for the question.
Currently now, it's really an economic discussion in terms of the cost of doing it.
And I use the ATM as just an example, but certainly if, for example, you had a sports bar that would want to do this in a real meaningful way, it would be an additional benefit to the business as well as us and in an adult-controlled environment.
And certainly, if we could configure it in a way with DraftKings to do that, that would probably be beneficial to all parties involved.
That's why I use the example.
Like I said, I'm just trying to make sure we drive revenue growth.
And that's certainly, I believe, my charge, our charge.
So follow up on that, if DraftKings wanted to open up a small couple of machines in my cellar, would that qualify as another location?
No, no, no.
It would certainly depend on your cellar first and the controls involved.
but certainly it's a discussion between DraftKings and us and the third party we're doing business with.
And that's obviously to drive revenue growth and also do it responsibly.
So it's more than just sort of a maximum number of locations.
It's more the correct, the ones that we believe benefit the state as well as the businesses.
Thank you.
Representative Abrami.
Yeah, I kind of want to rephrase what I was asking before making a statement as well here.
I want to pose a hypothesis that having the 10 limit removed could actually be a disincentive for others to jump in.
Why do I say that?
Again, there's a risk and expense to opening a sports book location.
And there's only so many people that actually are going to avail themselves to these locations.
So if I'm a business kind of guy and I want to open a book, now you're going to find out that there could be 50 of these around the state.
You know, I may have second thoughts about wanting to open one because we're taking the potential customers are being spread across, you know, 40 other locations that didn't exist before.
So I just think we've got to be a little careful about this.
Something to think about.
I don't know if Charlie, you want to react to what I just said.
I'm just thinking if I was thinking about getting into this business, and if it's limited to 10, okay, someone's going to do the math and say, okay, these many people are going to probably bet, and this is probably worth my while.
But if we're going to spread that across 50 locations, that's a different model.
That's a different discussion, I think.
Yeah.
To your questions, Representative Ibrami, if you're looking for smaller locations where there's less regulation, you're likely to be less risk tolerant there, if that makes sense.
Like ATMs have a limit on how much cash you can get but a teller doesn't same idea so like i said this is just speculation in the sense of what the next step would be i was just really trying to explain how we could run afoul of the 10 if indeed we were to um but yes if there were 20 locations in manchester versus, there'd be less incentive to do it because it's expensive.
But certainly, the market is dictating now that it looks like it does and will grow slowly.
You know, my sense is even with the 10, there's, I think within the 10, there's a market.
I understand about free market.
I agree 100% about free markets.
But I have a feeling that I don't think you're going to see more than 10, unless we change the rules here somehow, people jumping in, but to open it up to more than 10, I don't know, I think there might be this incentive to some businesses thinking about getting in.
That's all, thank you.
Of course.
Any other comments or questions?
Representative Elliott.
Mr.
Chairman, Representative Ames had his hand up also first.
Representative Elliott, when you hold off until Representative Ames asks his question.
Representative Ames.
Actually, I'm guessing that I came in after Representative Elliott, but I'll go.
So my question to Charlie McIntyre is, could you provide the committee with the description of the two sports books, locations, the retail operations that are set up now and operating in terms of size and activity and investment?
Any information that details and enables us to understand what's in place now.
The way I read the statute, I was just looking at the statute, there's very little definition of this concept in the statute.
It says the commission and its agents are authorized to operate physical sports book retail locations within the state.
This is the section of the statute that this bill amends.
And so it sounds like these operations are operated by the commission and its agents.
And I guess that's another part of my question.
Tell us how they're operated and what the lottery's involvement is in this as well.
Could you provide us with detailed information on the existing locations?
Sure, I'll certainly answer the question.
And if this follow-up, I'll happy to respond in writing thereafter, Representative Ames.
Yeah, that's what I was looking I was looking for yeah there's two facilities right now one in Seabrook and one in Manchester they're actually quite different in terms of construct the one in Seabrook they built what you would characterize as a stadium level seating leather couches hundreds of sports tvs they refurbished the Seabrook dog track and took one of the grandstands that was inside and made it into a theater type environment.
Very high end leather, all fitted.
They're at the very bottom of the stairs, which you would walk down a grandstand.
There are people who write tickets for you and you can watch games there.
You can also obviously bet on horse racing because they're the last facility with a horse racing license uh and they spent i don't know how much but i'm guessing it was in excess of a million dollars refurbishing that facility um they probably will do in excess of 50 million dollars in sports betting handle for the year they receive a percentage of the profit from that activity.
And that varies by week.
That's what we call a hold.
And that varies between six to 12%, say.
Averages around seven, seven and a half.
It's been a little better than that recently.
We've had some good weeks.
And so that's that facility.
It also is a charitable gambling hall.
So there's that function as well.
It's in a separate area from where the sports book is.
And the employees who write tickets, who actually take the wagers are employees of Seabrook.
There are the facility in Manchester is significantly smaller.
It's really next, it's in a shared space, but with a separate wall from what is a Greek restaurant and charitable gambling is also in a separate space in that facility as well.
Um, they have great food.
They sort of, um, focus on hospitality, food and beverages as well.
Uh, it's a smaller physical facility, much smaller.
It has a number of sports TVs running simultaneously.
And that facility will probably be in around $20 to $25 million in handle for this current fiscal year.
And like I said, their writers are their employees.
DraftKings has an employee dedicated to New Hampshire who does management of the retail sports book, who can make sure all their regulations and contract requirements are complied with.
And those two facilities in a nutshell are representative Ames aims and I can certainly go further in detail if you want.
Okay, I guess there is this question when I look at the statute it talks about the Commission and its agents as the entities that are authorized to operate these sports books so is that how do you how do you square that with what you just described who's operating these sports books.
So is that, how do you, how do you square that with what you just described?
Who's operating these sports books?
So it's pursuant to contract.
We have a contract with DraftKings.
And so DraftKings is our agent and they contract with subcontractors of who the facility is.
And they're held to that standard.
DraftKings has, I think, 11 similar arrangements around the country with different states, Indiana, Mississippi, New Jersey, et cetera.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Representative Elliott.
You're muted.
Can you hear me now?
Yes.
I have a question for Charles because the last time I saw him was about three weeks ago in front of the lavery building when I was cashing in a winning ticket.
So thank you, Charles.
Now, my question to you is, how long has this sports book been in operation?
Has it been five years, 10 years?
Just the fall.
We started in September.
We were supposed to open March 18th, I believe.
And then COVID hit and they closed the facilities obviously out of safety.
So they've been open since the fall, since September, I believe.
Oh, no, sorry, since August.
Since August.
Okay.
Well, the reason I asked that question, and I thought it was longer than that, but now I realize it wasn't, but I I agree with Representative Abrami that to take out that line that no more than 10 sports books should be in operation at any given time makes me wonder if it took us this long just to get two books that are open, why do we need to jump right away into 10 or more locations or eliminate that altogether?
Do you understand the question?
I do.
I don't know if it's a question for me so much as, you know, I don't know that we'd run afoul of 10 anytime soon.
It would be more, it would limit us in terms of expansion and sort of technology growth.
So another representative Lang-Wan has answered the question as well.
Thank you Mr.
Chair.
Charlie, what is your title now?
Commissioner or Director?
I forget.
I'm the Executive Director of the Hampshire Lottery.
I answer to a commission which acts like a board of directors.
They're part-time.
It's very much of a, I'm essentially Chief Executive.
I think that my counterpart closest would be Fish and Game executive director as well.
Fish and game commission.
Yeah.
This legislation, from your point of view, it sets a limit, but it's basically enabling legislation.
And if something decides to, or someone or some entity decides to open one of these things, they're the ones making the risk.
They either live or fail by their operation.
And you really don't care other than making money for the state, right?
Well, I do.
I care, obviously.
I want our partners to make money.
I'm very much an avowed capitalist.
And so I want them to do well, because if they do well, we do well.
Obviously, if they don't do well, it looks the facility will look downtrodden.
The customer will have a good experience.
All those good things.
Yeah, but it's not it's not like you're you're pushing this for you.
You're pushing this to allow an entity to succeed on their own merits, correct?
Yeah, I mean, honestly, yes.
Okay, we said this is Pat, Representative Ramia.
Representative Major, you going to step away a second, so I took the chair over.
Any follow-up, Jordan, you said?
No, I'm all set.
Okay, Representative Lang has his hand up.
I was just going to answer the question about locations and why we're moving this forward.
So one thing I do want to remind the task for the committee is that, you know, I served on the serve still on the governor's reopening task force.
And in phase one, all charitable gaming was shut down.
And so there was no charitable gaming happening at all.
So any chance for any business to open to do this kind of thing was shut down until as Charlie said, I believe it was August before I actually wrote the charitable gaming guidance for the reopening task force that the governor implemented so that they could reopen their businesses in a safe way and do it.
But there were still limits put on those businesses.
So even now, businesses have restrictions on them.
So the reason we're not seeing licenses move forward is because we're under these COVID restrictions that nobody wants to take the financial risk when the fact that you've got these restrictions put on them until unknown future at this point.
Again, and to Charlie's point about ATMs, if we're talking about the language in the bill, it says no more than 10 sports book retail locations.
So if Charlie and Charlie's vision of if the case at the Brook in Seabrook wanted to work with Loon Mountain to open up a satellite office, that would be considered a second location.
It's a second physical location of that sports book.
and so it would run afoul, even though we have only one licensee in that we would have the Brook as the charitable gaming operation, that would run afoul of the locations and that would classify, they would be using two locations up.
So again, the goal behind this bill was not to artificially limit.
I i don't anticipate we'll get to 10 any any rush but i also don't want to be pushing up against 10 and then waiting for the legislature to act so we can move um you know charlie is a phenomenal manager um he's done great great work with the sports book and i trust him to allow the businesses to open and and make sure they're profitable because if they're not profitable they're not going to be good for the state.
So he's not going to allow those businesses to open.
I am concerned to Greg Moore's comment of the medallions in New York is that if you limit this to 10, you know darn well that those, and we want to expand it in the future, those 10 locations are going to come in screaming they don't want it increased because they don't want to give up their market share.
And so, you know, I don't think it's the state's business to limit market share.
It's the retail operations choice to do a return on an investment, see if it works.
And if it does, then they open.
If it doesn't, then they don't.
It's Charlie's job to make sure that the state's risk is minimized as much as possible and we make revenue.
So I am concerned about the locations coming, going forward.
I want to see free market work if it, if it needs to, if New Hampshire goes that way, but I thank you for your testimony.
I know we've run over.
Okay.
Any more questions or comments?
Seeing none, I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 330.
Oh, I'm sorry.
on house bill 330, there were on the blue sheet, Tony Leacus, elected official, support.
Alyssa Leacus, elected official, support.
Eric Rothbund, member of the public, support.
Eric Rothman, member of the public support.
And Alexandria Meninawa in support, member of the public.
That's the blue sheet.
I'm going to open the public hearing on House Bill 354, an act relative to the local option for sports betting.
We've had a lot of betting today.
And the prime sponsor is Representative Lang.
He's going to introduce the bill and there is nobody else testifying for it except there's a blue sheet support from Eric Rothbard.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, committee, for again taking my testimony on House Bill 354.
This is a simple bill.
What I realized as I passed House, when House Bill 480 passed, which legalized sports gaming, and I saw the first ballot that contained the language that needed to go on the ballot in order for an municipality or a town to authorize sports betting, I realized that was horrific language.
It was terrible.
And I don't know how I let the bill get through the house that way without recommending a change.
The original language makes it sound like the town or city might somehow be liable for a sports retail book and like the town was going to become a bookie.
And so this bill just cleans up the language that goes on a ballot to make it more understandable to the voter.
The original language said, shall we allow sport operating book retail locations within whatever the town is, town of Samerton?
The new language cleans it up and it says, shall the city, shall the town of San Bernardin allow the operation of sports retail books within the city of town, or within the town of San Bernardin?
So I think it's just a housekeeping bill that just cleans up the language.
Like I said, I was down in New York City speaking on sports betting, and I think Charlie was there as well, and I saw the first ballot that I think the city of Franklin had.
And I was like, wow, that was really bad language.
We could have cleaned that up to make it easier for the voter.
And that's all this bill does is it cleans up the language to make a little more cleaner for the voter.
And I did work with Charlie in this language.
Any questions of Representative Lange?
Mr.
Chairman?
Representative Almey.
How did the previous language imply liability by the town and this one doesn't?
I don't quite understand.
They seem just about equivalent.
They are.
Again, they are fairly equivalent.
Again, it was my take on the read and I talked to Charlie as well and he thought it could be a little bit cleaner.
Again, I guess it's just personal.
As I read that when I in in new york and i read that first that ballot question on the city of franklin's ballot uh who did pass it by the way um it it just was cumbersome and i i also heard the same comments from people in the city of concord that there was actually letters to the editor that that um implied that the city was going to be somehow liable as a sports book.
And I just thought it was ugly language.
And I was trying to clean up the language to make it clear that the only thing that city and town is authorizing is a business opportunity for the city or town, that the town has no liability, whether or not they want to allow that type of business opportunity within their confines.ines um so again i i worked with charlie on this and it was we thought that this helped the voter get a little bit more clarity representative bronney representative lion thank you um i don't have any heartburn on this one this is fine uh do you know how many how many uh towns and cities have approved so far All right.
I don't have any heartburn on this one.
This is fine.
Do you know how many towns and cities have approved so far?
If I remember right, nine have, and Charlie may have a better number.
I think it was on 10 ballots and nine of them passed.
Actually, two of them failed.
Maybe it's 11 ballots and nine of them passed.
I think the city of Concord voted it down.
I can't remember.
No, they voted down.
Concord voted down something.
And then the second one was, I think it was Nashville, voted it down again.
And we heard some language around that as well.
The previous bill, you heard at one o'clock, why they wanted to have it repeated because I think it was unclear to the voter what they were voting on.
Can I ask Charlie a question?
Follow up.
Okay, Charlie, can you elaborate a little bit more on that?
Let's do which towns passed the sports book.
Representative Abrami, this is John Conforte.
Charlie had a meeting at 2.30 that he had to attend, so he's asked me to sit in for him.
That's fine.by, I think representative Lang, I think the numbers are correct with regard to the cities that first voted in November.
We then had a round of towns in last March, which also voted on the question.
I don't have the exact number of towns and municipalities, but I think about the success rate was about three quarters of the towns or cities who voted on the question.
Not everyone put it on their ballot, but I can certainly follow up with an exact number for you.
Yes, that would be great if you could maybe just give us the list of the towns that voted and the list of towns that successfully voted and voted down.
We can certainly do that for you.
Chair, thank you.
Hey Charlie, I mean I'm sorry, Pat.
Yeah.
Representative Ramey, I can tell you that in March there were 15 towns scheduled to, including Belmont, Derry, Hampton, Hinsdale, Hudson, Lincoln, Littleton, Milford, Newmarket, Pelham, Pembroke, Salem, Seabrook, Swansea, and Woodstock.
I don't know how many of those passed, but there were 15 of them that put it on the March ballot last year, after the November ballot.
Yeah, Representative Lange.
Yes.
That's great.
But if they can still provide that list, I can't write that fast.
And it'd be interesting to plot those on our map to get a sense of the locations that we can do here.
I think the goal is to spread it across the state as best we can.
So thank you.
I do think that question does go back to the number of locations, right?
So we just had 15 towns.
Plus we know there were nine cities before that is 24 potentials there that are looking for retail sports books.
Thank you.
Further questions or comments?
Representative Elliott.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay, my question is to Representative Lange, who said, quote, there's no liability, unquote.
I would like to know the source of that statement, Representative Lang.
Did you go to a lawyer?
So if your question is liability to the town?
Yes.
If that is your question, then the answer is within the contract that I'm sorry, I almost said fish and game because that's where I sit now.
the lottery commission signed that the lottery commission when it.
I'm sorry, I almost said fish and game because that's where I sit now.
The Lottery Commission signed that the Lottery Commission, when the contract that it has with DraftKings doesn't incur any liability to the local towns at all.
The liability is with the business owner himself and with DraftKings, and they share that liability.
Thank you.
Representative Tucker.
Yes, I had a question of one of the things that makes sports betting and betting generally different than other topics is that there already was betting.
It just wasn't legal betting.
and do we believe that having it now legal and the state able to participate in getting some revenue has reduced the amount of illegal betting?
Or do we not know?
Well, I can only speak anecdotally, because I do know some people that were betting were betting on games beforehand and that now use the DraftKings app.
So I can't give you any kind of statistics or numbers, but I can tell you that I know at least two people that are now using the DraftKings app.
Maybe.
James.
to the contracts that the lottery has that enable the sports book locations.
And they were mentioned by Director McIntyre as well.
And I had previously asked for details about each of the locations, but I didn't ask for the contracts that have authorized those.
So I'd like to add that to that request that uh we provide be provided we in the committee with the information about the sports book locations including the contracts that authorize their um that activity certainly representative ames we can provide that and just for the sake of clarity the state has only one contract with DraftKings.
DraftKings then subcontracts with those individual locations.
And just to put a little bit of a finer point on the previous testimony, in terms of the breakdown of responsibilities, DraftKings operates the technical aspects of the sportsbook in terms of the technology, the platform for taking the wagers.
And then the...
Kings operates the technical aspects of the sports book in terms of the technology, the platform for taking the wagers.
And then the location is responsible for the, the personnel to run the sports book and obviously for cash handling practices in the book itself.
But we would be happy to send you a breakdown of those division of responsibilities and certainly the contract that, that we have with DraftKings.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'm just doing this on behalf of Representative Tucker.
She hadn't had her question answered yet by the lottery department commission.
And I think she'd like to know if they've got any data on whether the illegal gambling on sports betting has declined since these two started.
Thank you, Representative Almi and Representative Tucker.
I'd be happy to attempt to answer that.
I think what we've heard anecdotally is that there's been a transition from people who were betting illegally onto the DraftKings New Hampshire lottery platform.
The other thing that we're seeing as more states are adopting legal wagering that we are seeing a softening in the illegal market, the offshore market that existed.
And in fact, recently, one of the larger offshore operators paid a fine to the United States Department of Justice in an attempt to come into the legal market.
So we are definitely seeing that we're not creating more wagering.
We're taking what was existing illegal wagering and bringing it into the light, bringing it into the legal market, which is obviously was one of the aims of this bill.
Any further questions?
Representative Ames, you have your hand up again?
No, no, no.
Okay.
Further questions?
I don't see any, so I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 354.
Thank you.
As a means committee, Representative Lang is going to head out, and I'll see you in a week or so when we talk about keynote.
Okay.
we're going to be discussing this bill again in our work session you Thank you, Ways and Means Committee.
Representative Lang is going to head out, and I'll see you in a week or so when we talk about keynote.
OK, we're going to be discussing this bill again in our work session on the 10th, along with all the other bills we have in the exec that we've heard to this point.
Anything from the committee?
Saying none is home.
Tom, I won't see you for a long time now, man, because it sounds like we're going remote.
They'll probably still...
I think this whole today made the decision for all of us right they um it would probably be put into the calendar as hybrid but we're going to do remote I think they gave us the wrong We don't want you to we can just ask on uh tuesday and wednesday is that mine yeah both of us are planning on is anybody going to be there are you talking to us or are you going to be leaving i don't think they understand about ending the meeting and or you wouldn't believe it?
I don't think they understand about ending the meeting.
Representative Bajor and Representative Abrami, is the meeting over?
Yeah, the meeting's over.
We can hear you.
I'm sorry.
I forgot.
Yeah, we couldn't tell whether this was the most